shane by the time you'd finished what
the fifth grade you'd already had
a hundred films and commercials under
your belt
do you remember those days i remember
those days
um as a youngster working in in
hollywood
i got my start and i was born in 1971
and the same year century 21
became a thing it was a big real estate
company
and a friend of my father's uh was
producing a series of commercials for
them and he said we're trying to appeal
to young families looking to buy homes
we need it we can't find a kid that can
sit and behave long enough to get these
takes done and you know i was literally
sitting in the corner chewing on
something and my dad said won't you take
him
so i started as a baby
actor in front of the camera those days
i don't remember
my first memory of working on set was
with june lockhart
you know from lassie and i worked with
june on some projects that my father was
producing
and then lloyd haynes from room 222 uh
ron masak who i'm still very dear with
who's ron's been in everything from
harper valley pta torre tortora
he was a velocic pickle stork murder she
wrote
and then was on um whitney in a robot
with david arkin back for nbc before i
was seven years old
um so i grew up
doing a lot of on-camera work as a
youngster and
what was really interesting is my father
got a contract with encyclopedia
britannica to do all their
what they called burns and poisons and
general safety films the educational
films of the 70s
why was that kid i was that kid that was
riding his bike across the street
without looking both ways and got hit i
was the kid who
ran out in the street after his frisbee
or his baseball and got hit i was
i was getting hit by cars in my dad's
video um
you know the kid that got electrocuted
because he put the paper clip in the
in the socket and what was weird was
this was mandated viewing in all the
schools growing up
so we would have these assemblies and it
was kind of weird because you were
stuck with 500 kids in this auditorium
watching your
your video and they'd watch you get
electrocuted i got to drown a couple
times i was the kid who got in the pool
and you know went after something when
nobody's looking and
drowned and yeah that was that was how i
started my career it reminds me of
scared straight
do you remember that i know it well i
remember
it just kind of reminds me of that was
also mandatory viewing yeah that's right
it was it was so so long story longer is
my father he had been a successful actor
in the 70s you know
and fell in love with filmmaking so he
went all out and bought
a moviola flatbed a couple of re-16
cameras that he had
and at a very young age i started
learning how to splice film run the
moviola
use an ra16 and be an assistant you know
whether i was doing the slate
or assisting the editors that would come
in to sync sound or splice film and
i actually enjoyed that kind of work a
lot more than
showing up on a set sitting around for
six hours to get 20 minutes of work in
very young so i retired in front of the
camera
probably before i was 11 or 12. those
days were behind me
but then by the time you were 19 you had
won two
emmys yeah i was nominated for four
emmys before
my 19th birthday and one and two okay
blessing or curse um you know
it sure was a blessing that night you
know i was the toast of the town i
remember going to the after parties and
hitting all those restaurants being that
that 16 year old kid walking around with
an emmy in the restaurant
that was cool but you go back to school
life goes on and i was
not sure what i wanted to do with my
life i was very fortunate to
have the opportunity to work in the
industry but i i wasn't passionate about
it i wanted to be
a drummer for a season i wanted to race
dirt bikes for another season and and my
interest
kind of followed that and i'd always get
back into working in our industry
because dad was doing a project he
needed help um
you know hey somebody needs an ac that
guy that worked on our last film needs
to hire an assistant cameraman i want
you to go work with him for the day so i
always got pulled back
in and didn't try and i think the curse
was here's somebody who didn't put much
thought or effort into what i did and
had four emmy noms and
two wins before i had really been a year
out of high school before i was old
enough to drink i was i was that deep
and when i finally decided to pursue
this industry
i made a decision to put the emmys in a
closet i got rid of them
out of sight out of mind for probably 10
years started at the bottom my father
had a wonderful assistant janet stone
who uh used to work at castle rock for
allens with belle and larry david
and i called her one day and said i want
to get into this industry i want to
start from the ground up i want to start
over
and and re re pave the way to where i
need to go
and she made a phone call for me and i
had taken a couple interviews and was
working at castle rock
uh shortly after and got fired from them
after a year
and uh was the best thing ever happened
to me because i learned that you know
what i thought i knew didn't matter i
learned how to become a good listener
didn't matter what i had achieved or
done before fortunately there wasn't the
internet or imdb so people didn't look
up their pa to see
what my history was so i started from
the ground up and
worked with castle rock for about a year
and a half on shows like seinfeld
seaquest
all-american girl roseanne
and then after getting fired wound up
working for
entertainment tonight for a year and a
half until
viacom took over the studio and then
from then went freelance and figured it
out
just started working wherever i could
doing whatever i could
what did getting fired teach you what it
really taught me was is
you know you can still put the emmys in
the closet but you still have
a sense of belonging you still don't
feel like
the bottom guy in the totem pole even
though i was i was hired as the office
pa at
you know 447 at universal studios during
taping of a lot of these big sitcoms so
i was
nothing and i
think because of my upbringing and
because of what i had experienced
i naturally felt like i had a sense of
belonging that may have not been
warranted just because of my own history
and that was on me
i knew i was in trouble when they had a
very famous director by the name of john
rich come
in to direct one of the episodes john
had done the brady bunch he's been
around
um i think he did sound of music
um wasn't john rich it was another
director
bobby wise forgive me forgive me
and um i was told nobody's allowed to
talk to him
he's a legend if you're below the line
you don't look at him you don't talk to
him well
i walk down the hall to deliver my smart
and final run
and bobby wise is in the cafeteria
making himself a sandwich or a bowl of
soup and i said mr wise how you doing he
looked at me and he goes what's up kid
and i said wells roots my uh my
godfather lee stanley's my dad and he
stopped everything gave me argues what
are you doing here let's
let's hang out and i think because i did
what i shouldn't have done
um it showed my bosses that i don't
listen well i didn't care what they said
i wanted to do what i wanted to do and i
only did that because
because he was a true friend of the
family my godfather and him had done
three movies together and
i knew who he was and i got fired over
that
wow so i learned quick uh follow
directions
it's interesting though we won't go too
deep into this but how sometimes it's
not
actually that if someone's ego was
offended but anyway
that i could i could tell you it was the
showrunner's husba
showrunner's wife was my boss and uh
when i got fired it was pretty
interesting i got brought in by the upm
who was
a wonderful human being who worked for
castle rock he said look you did nothing
wrong technically
it's just a weird dynamic man he goes
you know you're not supposed to talk to
a guy and you end up knowing this guy
and i mean this guy had been out of my
dad's boat three times i mean that's how
i knew i mean
why not say hi to him but i was told
don't talk to him
i should have told my boss look he's an
old family friend and i didn't
but and those are the yeah the unwritten
rules of hollywood that sometimes we
learn
unfortunately hence your your book that
you will go more into
thank you yeah okay
do you think if you had been in your 40s
and had won those two emmys or been
nominated for four
that it would have been a sweeter
victory or
you don't really think about that it's
just been your life you know that's a
great question
i think at the end of the day i often i
i i went through a phase where i assumed
up until i was 40 that i had peaked
at 16 or 17 or 18. i think that's a
dangerous thing i mean i
talk about i was very fortunate very
young to be a part of something that was
successful it wasn't me
it was the team and i was just a lucky
recipient i mean we had 33 emmy noms in
five years when
i think we won 13 or 14 emmys so i was
very fortunate to be a part of that
because of my camera work or the the
other production work that i did on
these shows
but you know you get to know childhood
actors growing up like macaulay culkin
or adam rich was a friend of mine or
you know working with charlie sheen for
many years and we talk about
peaking at a young age you know
charlie's great success
obviously he had tremendous success
through many years
capping it with two and a half men in
anger management but you think about
platoon and wall
street how that all happened before he
was really
before he's 22 years old um you talked
to adam rich about the success he had as
a youngster gary coleman and i
i always felt i could connect with those
guys because of that i understood what
it was like to be very lucky to be very
fortunate to be a part of something
i never took it for granted i never used
it
i don't think to my advantage but
i couldn't help but think as i was going
through my 20s and 30s
as i was trying to find my way and
create and write and produce or direct
or edit films
i i got to get this this kind of success
i got to achieve this
and though i had success through those
years
it wasn't until i was about 40 or 41
maybe it's that midlife crisis they all
tell us that you get at 40.
that i i realized that i was chasing
something that i was never going to
never achieve again it didn't mean i'd
never win an emmy again
but i wasn't going to win another one at
16. i was 40.
and you know so you see people go
through it every year hundreds of people
win a statue
that could be me again it might not be
um
but i think the excitement of it was the
fact that i was so young
and that's what made it special and you
can't go backwards you can't go back in
time
does the film industry make people crazy
and if not why that perception
yeah i think there's a a lot of crazy
that comes hand in hand with being an
artist anyway there's an eccentricity
with creative beings
we're dreamers i think any time you you
[Music]
live your life based on kind of playing
the odds of the lottery how does it not
make you crazy as
i talk about in my book what other
business do you know of really you know
music
film dance art where you could literally
be homeless living on a friend's couch
and get an audition
for that one role and become
the next gal gadot you could become the
next you know
jason bateman you can be anybody and you
know you think about doctors lawyers
successful business people they they
have a path
they still may be trying to figure out
that path but they usually go to college
they'll often figure out a plan and a
road
get get their eye on a prize and work
their way to it you know
medical school being six years and then
residency that's that's a game plan
for artists for what we do the game plan
is bust your ass
you know make it you'll fake it till you
make it you know it's it's
never give up it's i can't quit because
my break may come tomorrow
and i think a lot of people uh
coming up that way and trying to find
their path uh in their place
it can make you crazy i've found trying
to find my path has made me a little
nuts sometimes as i say a little south
of sanity
um i also find once we get in a position
of authority
it's i think no other industry is as
uh is unkind
as ours and i know everybody says
there's horrible people in every
industry i've been around every industry
you can imagine because of what i do and
the things that i've experienced
and shot and i it it's
mind-boggling how people are treated and
yeah the i think the me too movement
and then the aftermath of that and
people and how we talk to one another
was so long overdue
but it's it's amazing what people get
away with and i still think they get
away with it know how they talk to each
other and treat people
i and i that that can make people crazy
you know i think it does
sure what about people's reactions to
artists
you know there's all these sort of
stigmas that artists are selfish or
whatever
can we talk about other people's
reactions can i swear
uh okay one swear word one f mom
okay i i have a brother who i i love
more than anything he's very successful
and he has a motto that he's always kind
of looked at
what with what we do and he's always
said look you want to be an artist go
paint in a park on saturday
get a job life's a business don't
don't you know life's life goes by fast
you don't want to look back when you're
40 or 50 and wonder what happened
you know he's the smart squirrel that
always stashed away during the winter
you know for the winter months and i i
see that i i came from
a my mother was from manhattan uh from
new york
a very successful lawyer was her father
she was a very successful real estate
agent
her brother is a you know was the
director of primary care for kaiser
and the fact that i didn't go to college
the fact that i just wanted to be a
dreamer
uh figure out what i'm gonna do with
myself and you know the three choices i
picked were were
music dirt bikes and films so you don't
need a college education for either and
all of them are pretty
pretty big shots in the dark i think
people look at artists
and uh as i call us um
[Music]
you know people who who express
themselves for a living
a lot of people don't understand it i i
find when i talk with different schools
different institutions a lot of parents
um are more supportive now than they
were when i was growing up because
you have things like you know somebody
like mark zuckerberg coming along and
creating facebook you have somebody who
created twitter or pinterest and
all these things that one day they they
wrote a code for something
that made him a billionaire overnight so
i think we have a little
more leeway and a little more grace from
people who look down at the dreamers and
the
the creative beings but i still i still
get sad when i talk to a lot of the the
youngsters coming up and it's like they
don't have the support from their family
especially
the ones that are going to community
college because they don't have the
financial means
to put themselves to a good school and
they certainly don't have the support
of parents i actually encounter some
very well to do
people in the community colleges whose
parents are like i'll write the check to
go to usc tomorrow
you want to go to yale we'll make it
happen but you're going to go down this
path you're on your own
and i think that's unfortunate um so i
think there's a little bit of a stigma
still um but i don't think it's as bad
as it was
when when i was coming up do you think
people and community colleges i know
we're going off on a little bit of a
tangent but
are less competitive with one another i
mean i went to a community college
at that time the internet was just
starting up so you couldn't look
somebody up and say oh
what's this person's deal so you could
be more anonymous but i felt like it
wasn't like
uber competitive and i was able to enjoy
myself there
i've gotten to the point where whenever
a community college says
would you could you can you the answer
is yes
because there's a purity there is a
drive there is a determination without
prejudice
i find a lot of the people at community
colleges now are on their second
their second wave of life they're often
parents
they take buses and public modes of
transportation to get to school
they're putting themselves through you
know paying a few hundred dollars a unit
to try to get
to something and i enjoy
that crowd a lot um i do work with a lot
of universities and i
appreciate and cherish that time too but
the mindset
is different um i can tell you without
naming names there are
universities that accept the fact that
their students will not
finish their thesis film after having
three years to do it and they still get
a beautiful diploma and march down
march down the uh the stage and
i i don't understand that our business
will not
hire you if you don't finish a task if
you don't
show up and you don't deliver you don't
work so i don't know why you'd reward
them and and i had a chair at a very
prominent
film school university tell me once we
don't want to deal with the lawsuits
so we passed them and if i'm breaking
protocol by coming out and saying that i
don't care that's how it is
and that doesn't happen at community
college you have guys like dan watanabe
and
chris rossiter and some wonderful
teachers who have been that and done
there and spent more time on a set than
most university professors have
and they are very happy to fail you
uh if you don't do the work and i
appreciate that because that's how it is
remember alex p keaton from family times
he was always marty mcfly he was always
throwing community colleges under the
bus that was his like
go-to thing but i i think they are
salt of the earth and i and i i it's
funny i will tell you when they first
when i first wrote my book
and a few of the universities were
getting excited and a few blacklisted me
and
just by the title of the book because i
used to be welcome to give lectures and
workshops and speak and then as soon as
they read the manuscript it was oh
well the title of your book you're out
and it's like i have no problem with
film school
if you didn't grow up around it you need
to learn these things all i want to do
is teach you what they don't teach you
there's the business of the business of
distribution and
how to get financing you know not french
new year or what angle to put the camera
and the lights at there's so much more
to learn
doing your own deals production deals
distribution agreements
actor agreements how to approach talent
how to approach money you don't talk
about that in film school that's what i
that's what i teach and when i first
got people excited about the book and it
started like well you know there's
there's nine community colleges out
where you are and we'd really love to
get you roped in with them i
at first was a little kind of like what
am i getting into here
and i went and spoke for my first time
at a community college and i never
looked back i
loved the passion these people had and
they're not kids
we have people our age there i mean
there's i go to some of these workshops
there's people in their 60s and 70s
trying to figure out
their next chapter and i love that
they've been that done there they're old
souls they've lived
they've scrapped for everything they've
got they've fought for every piece of
real estate they own
usually and i i just think that makes
for
better artists i think it makes for
better human beings
shane in your book what you don't learn
in film school you say you've been rich
and you've been poor you like rich
better
what did each experience teach you what
happened
how did you get from point a to point b
and back you know
i've been rich i've been poor and i of
course you like rich better you want to
be able to take your loved ones out to
dinner you want to be able to
take a vacation you want to be able to
pay a mortgage
bill or a phone bill when it comes in
without breaking a sweat and figuring
out where that's going to come from
um you know when you when you start out
you know i was very stubborn i wanted to
prove my independence maybe it came from
being unlucky enough to win two emmys
before my 19th birthday but you know for
my 18th birthday i graduated high school
on my 18th birthday june 15
1989 i was in my first
condo living on my own within a couple
months after that
i moved right out and my parents didn't
want me to leave they didn't they
weren't saying hey
get your life together you need to get a
house or move out i just was like wanted
my independence
and you know it was amazing you don't
when you're not educated
like me in the fundamentals of life
sense
i was an old soul when it came to
dealing with the things that i had seen
and experienced and witnessed as a young
kid
but i you know really taught me how to
balance a checkbook nobody taught me
about
where to put money or how to how to
manage money so i was that kid that
would make five
grand and spend 10 you know the next day
just assuming and then forgetting there
were taxes and bills and
you know so i um
i learned very quickly how fast money
goes i learned very quickly how you have
to
promote yourself to work we're we're
sales people in this industry we're
we're selling widgets which are
ourselves we're selling a product
whether it's a script or us as an actor
or a filmmaker
and i learned what it's like to
file bankruptcy when i was in my 20s i
learned what it was like to
be evicted when i was in my 20s i
learned what it was like to have a car
repossessed when i was in my 20s and
then another car repossessed when i was
in my 20s and another car repossessed
after that in my 20s
so you know finally a light goes on and
say okay this isn't working and then you
learn how to manage and then you know
you have success you work hard you know
it's fortunate i was a part of some
successful projects
and i liked rich better because i wasn't
getting my cars repossessed
and i was able to go to nice dinners
when i felt like it and i was able to
you know
pay rent or mortgage and not sweat um
plus those are some big guys
repossessing those cars there's some big
guys and i learned at a young age not to
fight them either i learned the hard way
when they don't
collect no they don't mess around those
guys because they don't get paid unless
they bring a car back and you know i
didn't know that
you know and those crowbars they have
that they
they they don't mind swinging at them i
mean they'll they'll hit you with them
but uh
anyway um so i
when when it came around again i
learned to be a little bit more
responsible
not to live outside my means
and i i i'm not rich or poor now i
i make a living being a filmmaker i'm
comfortable
um i don't ever take anything for
granted
i don't regret any decisions i've made
or what i've experienced
um sure we'd all like to to be able to
just
thumb our nose and only do what we want
when we want but that's not what life's
about i've been in those
chapters where you know you can go four
or five years and not worry
about work and it's easy to become
complacent it's easy to become
put things in cruise control and lose
the edge lose the venom as i say
and i find when i think of myself in a
situation of needing to provide for
my family when i think about needing to
keep a roof over my head
and wanting to be able to have a nice
dinner once a month or to take a little
road trip with my wife
it reminds me i got to keep my my nose
to the grindstone and i never get
complacent i'm always grinding
can we can we hear a story about a great
time
where you you had the 5 000 payout and
spent 10
and then maybe times when yeah things
were really bad and
i'll give you a better one i remember
the 25
000 days those were the fun ones
you know when you get a phone call out
of the blue it's like hey we need you to
do a commercial it only pays 25 grand
but we'll only need you for five hours
can you come in
sure i'll be there and you know and i
had a loan out company so they'd take
out taxes so you know you're getting a
check for 25 grand
and that's for like four hours of work
that doesn't it's not a bad day you know
or
i remember selling a script um my first
screenplay i ever sold i got 125
thousand dollars for it i wrote it in
two weeks
it doesn't happen often but you forget
about agents managers
lawyers business managers taxes that
that 125 grand turned into about
fifty one thousand dollars really quick
i had already bought two new cars four
jet skis two motorcycles
and took a bunch of friends to vegas so
you know stupid is easy come easy go
right
so you know that happens um as far as
being broke i
i remember uh renting a house and
knowing deep down inside i couldn't
maintain it but boy it sure looked good
at the moment and made me feel like the
king of the mountain because it was on
top of a mountain in the valley
and i remember after three months
getting a call from the landlord he's
like i'm sure you know but you know
you're check bounced and i was like
okay and i'm looking at my bank
statement i got 320
to my name i just bounced to 2600 check
yeah you know and then you're you're
robbing peter to pay paul
to to make rent and uh
next thing you know you're you're living
with a buddy in his two-bedroom
apartment paying him 300 bucks until he
could figure it out again and you know
because of this crazy business
i got a phone call and went off and did
a five million dollar movie
six weeks later and i was back at it
again you know making good money
all in the unions and it's crazy
business
so what i've learned to do is is to just
just be and treat every every job as
your last
and every dime that you get that you may
never get another and i'm not
stingy you just become more prudent as
you get older
you know i'm going to be 50 next year
you know i don't want to have to keep
hustling when i'm 70. i'd like to do
only what i want to do when i'm 70.
and i've been lucky i get to do what i
want to do but there's still the desire
to get out and work so i don't
have to worry those friends that you
took to vegas do you still talk to them
incidentally no
[Laughter]
no
no so when the money went away those
friends went away
it's like you hear about all the sports
athletes and rock stars and the actors
that when it's good it's good and when
it's bad it's bad it's the same for us
behind the scenes guys you know when
you're
19 20 21 years old and you're burning
through 250 300
000 a year living on your own without
any responsibilities you're the life of
the party
and then when you got to start telling
your friends you know that's why i
bought so many jet skis because i wanted
my friends to come out and jet ski with
me they couldn't afford their own so
i'll buy three or four let's go out
together
and then you know they call you and say
hey let's go jet skiing this weekend and
you're like
yeah i sold them well those group of
friends fall away
and then you know hey i need to borrow
your your truck this week i i got to do
something well i don't have the truck
anymore i've only got my
you know my my two-seater right now or
my four-seater cars like oh and then
those people go away
you know it's just like fairweather
friends sure i i have some great friends
i've known all my life but the people
that went to vegas back then
no i don't see them anymore
shane in your new book what you don't
learn in film school was there a chapter
or
section that sparked controversy oh
absolutely
um i think the most controversial
chapter in the book is the one that's
the most important and that's to get out
dig ditches get your hands dirty and
make yourself available
and whatever it takes to get on a set
within
your morals values and ethics parameter
to go do it
and when i came up as we talked about
how i made phone calls and hustled to
get work and get on sets i worked for
free i brought my own lunch
i showed up first and left last i was
sweeping floors when it wasn't in my job
description and i have
close friends that our generation grew
up
you know i have a friend whose father
won two oscars and his mother has nine
emmys
you want to talk about nepotism and when
he got his act together like i did he
said hey you know yeah i want to work in
this business i want to be an editor
mom picked up the phone made a phone
call okay he'll be there tomorrow
two o'clock perfect thank you click
you got a job you're sweeping floors it
color deluxe
you're getting paid nothing pack a
launch deer and he swept floors
deluxe for two years i think it was
deluxe and
he didn't have a problem with that he
thought that's normal
i had won emmys at a young age and
started over and we talked about not
being able to make rent well there was
something called crew call back when i
was coming up
and you would literally subscribe for
like 50 a month
you would call an 800 number and you
would say you know press one for camera
press two for sound press three for
you know electric and you would press
these things that you could do
and then you would hear about jobs and
you would write it down and it would
give you a fax number and you would fax
your resume you would spend a day a week
doing that
and pray your phone rang and sometimes
it wouldn't
so a friend would call and say hey i
need a i need a swing
in the camera department tomorrow i pay
lunch you enter out and i was like yeah
i'm there
the biggest problem i have today is when
i talk to film schools or when people
read that chapter
about having to invest in yourself and
build your resume you know so many
people are in my opinion in film school
are sold on hopes and dreams
and um being the next tarantino or
damian chazelle
and my advice is well if that doesn't
happen what's the game plan
so get out and learn camera learn sound
learn editing
learn grit learn gaff learn ac whatever
you can
and if somebody can't pay you to do
something and you have an opportunity to
make new contacts
learn and be on a set something good
will come from that
do you would you rather sit home and
play on your phone or play xbox or watch
repeated
streaming shows that you've seen six
times you want to get out and make new
contacts
and i find a lot of people uh think
that's not the way to do it
and i also think okay well over 85
percent of people who
spend money and graduate from film
schools never earn a dime in our
industry
and there's a reason for it and that's
because they are uneducated on how to
make their lives
work and how to build a career base and
contacts and become steady earners in
our business and the way i did it the
way i know a lot of people who did it
was they got out there and proved their
worth by
hustling and some of the best workers
like we just felt finished a film called
break even that comes out
some of the best workers on that film
were the interns from lake pierce
college
there's a kid that stands out
he worked so hard every day
never said a word head down he
anticipated everybody's needs he was the
guy that was cleaning up everybody's
trash at the end of the night
showed up on days he wasn't supposed to
be there just because he wanted to check
in
say i'm coming in tomorrow does anybody
need anything you know
what i always tell people is when you
make a movie and you're trying to carve
your way
make it so the decision makers don't
want to make a movie without you
and every time you do a film you sure
meet a lot of people you never want to
make another movie with but
it's nice when you see those one or two
diamonds in a rough that you say god i
i want to bring them back and they were
they were somebody who was a pa they
were
an assistant they were a runner and i
think if people take that approach as
as i say in the book um whenever you
offer somebody a job it's
what's my credit what's my pay it's
always the first question
what's my credit what's my pay and i
think it needs to
be okay you know take a breath
and think about what the experience can
do for you i mean i talked in the same
chapter i talk about the the best thing
i ever did for my career was say yes to
something i knew nothing about
i did it for free and it took up a month
and a half of my life
and that was going to bali indonesia
with zalman king when he directed in
god's hands
solomon had seen my work ethic around a
sound stage he owned in canoga park
i was sweeping floors and he's like he
walked in and he goes i thought you were
producing or
doing something more important i said
yeah everybody left i wanted to leave
your studio the way we found it and he
says what's your name and he came over
and he talked to me and
we befriended each other and he came and
visited the next day on set and
next thing you know he called me up and
he said hey what are you doing in
november or december
and i said i don't know what do you got
and he said well i'm doing a film in
bally i think i think uh you should come
i said do what he said shadow me learn
he goes i'll offer you free education
working with me and
and we'll feed you and travel you and
you figure out the rest
you didn't pay me a dime and it was it
was like talk about film school you're
sitting next to
zalman freaking king as he's directing a
movie for a major studio
and i was on his hip for a month and a
half doing that and i learned more
by just saying yes and then ask what i
get a credit and what i get paid
you know and they limited me to the
airport and first class me round trip
gave me my own bungalow and in a
five-story resort i didn't ask for any
of that i didn't i probably know i'd be
sleeping in a tube tent on the side of a
mountain
you know but they took care of me and uh
i think
that's the attitude obviously you don't
want to be taken advantage of you don't
want to get into a situation that's not
healthy but
there seems to be such resistance in
getting out and
experiencing work without worrying about
pay there's too many people that'll do
it
do you think that's because for you know
our generation gen x
that there wasn't the term intern you
know and some of the
let's play the devil's advocate yes
interns can be taken advantage of in
terms of
absolutely people using free labor and
and not stringing them along and not
giving them a job
is that what they're afraid of i don't
know i think honestly
um i think as a society we would become
pretty tender
i think we become very sensitive and i
think people are afraid of exploitation
which i think
is something we all need to consider but
you know
i i know i've got a nephew who worked as
his you know what off working for a
financial institution in arizona
and scottsdale working 18 hours a day
getting their lunch
cleaning up their mess getting them
coffee you didn't get paid much at all
but now he's
an actual worker in that industry and he
used that
after colleges wasn't for college
credits he graduated college
his dad made a few phone calls and said
you're going to go sweat you're going to
wear a tie and you're going to go
you're going to go ride their their wave
you're not going to get paid you're
going to learn
it happens in other industries but
it's just seems in ours i think it's
because the hours are abused
you know and if in a normal workplace
it's an eight-hour work day with an hour
break in film it's 10-12 if you're lucky
and
i think people are afraid they're going
to be working 16 18 hours a day as free
labor
so it's hard to say why but i never
questioned that i
maybe maybe it was just the fact that i
could be on a set and make connections
and learn and i always figured well
i could sit at home and wait for the
phone to ring or i could be on a set and
meet a director or a producer who may
find my my job skills
necessary to bring me to the next
journey and then make a great connection
and say by the way i have a script
by the way you know i also do camera can
i get an opportunity
and it doesn't happen by sitting at home
it just doesn't
great okay excellent at least i don't
think it does i mean you can upload
youtube and vimeo
until you're blue in the face
yeah but working with you know being
around people is is a different
experience absolutely
there's good and bad best gigs and best
opportunities i ever had in my life were
showing up and working hard and proving
myself as a worker
who was competent and the people in the
decision-making capacities going out of
their way to say hey you know appreciate
your work today thank you and then
you know we've got something coming up
next week i want to get you on that
and then they start to appreciate you
and you work these gigs and
next thing you know you have an audience
you have an ear with the decision makers
and when you want to move up in the
world or they know people that will
benefit by knowing you
that's all it is in this business
what caused you to leave the film
industry for what two years
two years i did to do some soul
searching
i i i needed a break i you know
i i got my first national commercial i
was nine months old
i had gone through the highs and lows
the riches and poor's been through a
divorce
marriage and a divorce rather quickly
and you know as i used to say my life
was trying to have a
like having a picnic at the runway at
that time in my life it was very
just very a lot going on it's very
turbulent
and i i was approaching 30
i was in my late 20s and
you kind of hit rock bottom emotionally
i wasn't
you know suicidal i wasn't destitute
but i was emotionally done i had been
doing one thing and one thing only for
so long
even though i i dabbled in other hobbies
or career paths suggest
you know ideas coming up i had only done
one thing
and i i needed a break
i just needed you know it's one of those
things is this really what i want to do
is this something i want to continue
doing is this something i want to
pursue and put the next chapter or the
next 30 years of my life into you know
when you start coming up on 30
you do a lot of soul searching you're
not a kid anymore you know your 20s are
coming up being over and you got to
start thinking you know
things haven't gone as i thought they
would or i hope they would is this
something i want to keep doing
and it was the best thing i ever did i
actually went and sold
cars i went and sold cars for a ford
dealership
for galp and ford and it happened by
accident i was having lunch with the
owner's son we were good friends
and his father came in who owned a
dealership he came in he looked at me
and he said you look like
you don't look too good and he said you
look like your soul's been bought and
sold down a river a half a dozen times
and i said yeah it's been a rough go i'm
going through a divorce
going through bankruptcy and i'm just
you know
business closed down one of my partners
went a little cuckoo
and he said well why don't you come sell
cars and i said what are you nuts
i sell cars and he looked at me and he
said you've been peddling that
crap you call art for the last 20 years
you made a living doing that
you got the number one ford dealer in
the world cars sell themselves you never
went to college you don't know how to do
anything other than what you do why
don't you learn and get an education
learn how to listen
learn how to sell he goes i promise you
when you quit here
if you decide not to stay you will take
what you learn here and be better at
what it is you think you can do
and boy was he right that was my college
education selling cars
what was that first morning like getting
ready to go to galpin
well they stuck me in a four-week
training course
so i went and learned how to sell for
four weeks under lou brown who was a
very
world-renowned car sales guru that used
to tour the world and
teach salesmen getting ready to hit the
floor how to sell
i could i would always been told i could
sell ice to an eskimo
and we had 18 graduates in my
class and i was the last one to sell a
car it took me
three and a half weeks to move a car and
it got to the point where my boss pulled
me aside and said if you don't sell a
car today i'm gonna
tr i'm gonna request you to be
transferred or fired because you're
you're not you're not moving anything
and
there was a cop that used to drive by
the dealership he lived in palmdale he
worked at lapd
nicest guy in the world he used to stop
by and visit me every other day
and you know he would just he i
encountered him one day on the lot and
we hit it off and i
you know i have a heart for cops and he
was a neat guy and
i thought he wanted to buy a ford
explorer and he
would talk to me about it every day and
finally you know at that time my boss
yelled to me said you don't sell he
showed up the guy showed up that he said
you don't sell him a car today you're
done
so i walked out and he wanted to see me
and i'm walking around a lot with him
and i he looked at me and he said you
seem a little like something's up what's
on your mind you know he's a cop they're
intuitive right
he was a detective he's like what's
going on you see him a little i said
sir if you don't buy a car for me today
i'm going to get fired and he goes
you're kidding me your boss said that
and i said yeah and he goes well we
can't have that happen
i like it in the blue let's wrap this up
never saw him again he bought the car
and never saw him again
the cool thing is i sold another car
that day and then i started to become a
good salesman it was just about doing
that
and that's what i try to use in teaching
a lot of the kids about writing their
first screenplay
uh going on their first audition working
on their first show
shooting your first project even if it's
on your phone
until you do it you don't know what it's
like and once you do it it gets easier
and you'll fail
you'll make a lot of mistakes do it
again fail again
but every time you do it you're not
going to make the same mistake twice
it's like
i've been at this a long time i've been
a producer filmmaker going on 30 years
and i make mistakes every time i i make
a film i make
i make mistakes but i don't make them
twice
so every time i make a movie i make a
new mistake and then next time i know i
won't make that mistake again
and you grow you grow and and that's
what i try to
encourage the young the young
storytellers coming up is it's okay to
fail
fail often get it out of your system
when did you feel you were ready to go
back in you had sold some cars maybe you
got your confidence back up
i worked i committed to do a year i
ended up working 18 months
with galpin and it was the most
incredible years of my life i'm still
very close to the ownership i'm still
very close to a lot of people i sold
cars with and i'm still close to some of
the customers i sold cars to
i was in 18 months there were some
issues with a manufacturer that was not
ford but that was very public
when they had tires that were ripping
off of cars
and i had sold probably 300 ford
explorers over my 18 months there and i
came into the office one day and had
over 300 messages on my
my phone after taking a weekend off and
it was customers freaking out
and i realized that this is probably a
bit more than i
this is this is it's time and and it
that i
had been nurturing that i had passed on
two movies that had come to me during
the time i was there because i wanted to
commit to
to the family that that brought me a job
and provided me a very good living
working there
and an opportunity but it was the it was
the fire debacle with the ford explorers
that was
the end for me that's when i turned in
my uh my name plate and turned over my
sales books and said it's
i'll give you two weeks and they said we
don't do that here you know we don't and
that's just a policy because they don't
want you taking customers in case you
sell cars elsewhere which i never did
but i that's why i left i was that was
it was time and i stepped right into a
great film that i did with my father
and uh never looked back and that was in
99. have you ever thought about taking
that story of working for the car
dealership working for galpin and
turning it into a screenplay
i've thought about turning my
experiences into working in the car
sales business
many times um there was a great
film done years ago called suckers which
shows the dark side of a dealership now
the cool thing about a dealership in
gallpin is a first class organization i
mean they're
the best in the world at what they do
but there's still the the people that
work there that make it interesting the
family runs a tight ship
they're the best in the business they
sell more cars than anybody but you
still have
the riffraff's and i say that with with
with
fun because what i what i learned is in
lou brown's class he said nobody sells
cars for a living
because they said i want to sell cars
for a living people if you think about
it everybody who sells cars didn't grow
up single and sell
cars they failed at something else they
they went through a divorce
they they had hardships they lost to
business and and it was so true i
remember in our class that we had 18
people graduate 35 of us started
everybody else had a story about a
career that failed or a job that closed
down or a divorce
or a circumstance so you have these
unbelievable people from all walks of
life from all nationalities all
different classes
of financial and background and pedigree
but there was a film called suckers that
i watched and it
it was so scary on the nose when it came
to the business of the business that i
thought you can never
you're never gonna touch that so i
developed a tv series
that when i was working with david
madden at fox i
got very excited about i was developing
tv shows for fox
when david was there and um
everybody loved the concept they thought
it was great but you'll notice there's a
reason that car sale shows are not on tv
and that's because the number one
sponsorships of your ad dollars are
usually
car sales car manufacturers you know
you've got mazda you got buick you got
honda you got chevy you got kia
it's endless and they take those prime
time slots to
show families what they could be driving
so if you
are going to tell the true story of the
business
you're not going to get those ad dollars
so i found through some really high up
connections in in television sales
broadcasting and
decision makers that you're not the
first who's come with the idea
it's a great idea that we can't touch
because that's where our dollars come
from
so but now that there's a streaming
ability i should recircle that you know
that's something worth
thinking about because you know if
you're doing a show on netflix you're
not worried about selling cadillac
commercials
this is off topic a little bit but then
glenn gary glenn ross was okay
wall street wolf of wall like so it's
okay to see
one sector of sales yeah but that was in
car sales
right it's it's the fact that buick if
you watch a network show
watch this as us i know you're probably
doing what i do and skipping through
your commercials on dvr
i guarantee you a third of the ads you
see on any show are going to be from car
manufacturers
if you show a show that shows the dark
side
of that business how do you get a car
company to pay for ads of that show
you're going to have a hole in the
advertising but you're right but those
were films
glengarry gun ross was a great film wolf
of wall street great film
but wall street is its own thing they're
not buying ad dollars they're just you
know
pulling the strings of our globe any way
you like but
i i just thought of it as we're sitting
here talking is you know you can do
series for amazon you can do them for
netflix you can do them for all sorts of
different outlets
that don't require ad dollars coming in
so maybe it's time to dust off some of
those and
[Music]
and it's also nice because you can kind
of cross some lines and push the
envelope on those platforms too
you could do an ensemble thing like with
crash where you you focus different
different stories people getting ready
to go to his training class anyway best
thing i ever had happen is i remember
taking a family of
six i remember taking a very nice
conservative family of sex on a test
drive in a uh
i forgot i think was the wind star ford
windstar family van
and i remember the father was driving
and the mother was sitting and i'm
sitting in the next rows with all the
kids
and all of a sudden the father he's
doing like 55
60 miles an hour down to poverty
boulevard he looks up slams on the
brakes
and what happened was one of the
salesmen had taken a nap in the back of
the windstar
and woke up during the test drive and
father's driving all of a sudden this
guy with his hair all disheveled
it could have been a porter or somebody
popped up from the back
i mean that's kind of that happens at
dealerships i mean you're dealing with
crazy people walks like they're party
animals i've partied with you know
poison guns and roses motley crew and
van gaal and all in the same night with
charlie sheen on the side
and i will tell you the people that work
at car dealerships they can drink them
all under the table
i kid you not that's a whole different
breed
that's awesome sorry no that's really
funny that's really funny
that's a great story without naming
names
can you tell us a story about how a
studio took
was it your script or one of your ideas
which time
um i i'm really a big proponent on
protecting your work
i will go on record to say don't waste
your 20 or 30 doing wga west
it's a waste of time doesn't do any good
um it's not going to
do what you want it to do spend the
extra 25
and do it with the usco the u.s library
of congress
u.s copyright office is what that stands
for the process is just as easy
the copyrights last forever not five
years copyrights
cover your legal expenses to defend the
fact that you got ripped off
and as we're young and naive coming up
in hollywood we tend to
really love to share our work with
people and i always tell people
don't you dare send a script to anybody
until it's finished and copy written
because it's too easy the person you're
sending it you could steal it the person
that you sent it to could send it to a
friend who needs an idea
or hey i'm thinking about getting into
screenwriting do you have any scripts
laying around i can look at and kind of
use as a model the easiest thing to do
for a new writer is to look at somebody
else's work and just
copy it what happens i've been ripped
off over the years i actually had a
script get produced by a studio
who i'll not name they actually went out
made the movie it was a 9 million dollar
indie low budget film that they
they put the money behind to make and
they were dumb enough not to even change
the title of the film
or the character names so i guess
whoever brought it to them
took my work and just put their name on
a cover sheet and just
did it as is i gotten wind of this when
they were in
post and what you're supposed to do when
you get ripped off is you
let the film come out like let it get on
the books and let the trailers start
hitting and then that
that monday before the friday is when
you drop your bomb
because they are so vested in this with
the 20 million in p
a or whatever it is they're gonna work
out a deal with you and instead stupid
here knew
somebody who knew somebody who worked at
the studio when i heard it was in
post-production i made noise about it
and then the film just disappeared it
never came out it was never finished
but they indeed um my friend got me a
copy of the script there was a polish on
the script but they kept the names the
same they kept the title the same
i go on imdb it's still there unreleased
15 years later but uh it's just kind of
funny
this movie got made that never never
even got finished
no release so that was one i've had
agencies uh take projects and give them
to show runners
days after we meet on them
sometimes hours after
i've had a project that was packaged by
a major agency
and an 07 when the crash hit my
investors backed out
we were three weeks away from rolling
film and you know when the
the 07 recession hit my investors had to
back out so the project never got made
and then
weirdly enough two years later the
packaging agent
got a new client who shot pretty much
the same script
wound up making it into sundance and
doing quite well
and at least they changed the title they
changed the character names
and the best part was they changed the
opening scene but the rest of the movie
was pretty much
in step so you know i don't make noise
about that stuff anymore
i've learned and that's probably why i
become an independent filmmaker
if i have an idea i'm passionate about
i'm not sending it to you i'm just going
to go make it
that's where i've gotten is i just don't
share my work with anybody if
something i believe in and want to do it
stays in-house and
we'll do it so that's usually how a lot
of people do it if they feel their ideas
been stolen
they wait till the week of well you'll
often hear about a film that comes out
and you'll hear
writers are making noise they said their
idea was taken and that's usually when
the film is coming out and what happens
is you get the studio
or the network so vested in the project
they've completely paid the entire
process
now they're going through the marketing
and pa and they've committed a good year
a year and a half to the project
and then all of a sudden it's coming out
and you know it's not common but
it's not rare where you hear this
movie's coming out and there's a couple
of writers who say that they were
ripped off and more often than not those
stories disappear and go away
and i think if you're able to prove it
i always say you know you have to take
copious notes i always say
i have a backup email address so anytime
you send a script to somebody send it to
another address you have and
keep those things print them out save
them on a cloud so you have a track
record if you send a script to somebody
you have a conversation with somebody
keep a journal hey i spoke to this agent
at this agency on this day about this
actor and this project
because you know it's just if you're
gonna ever make noise that you
were ripped off you have to have you
have to have
chapter and verse copious notes on
everything that that you've done or
there's just no
you know ideas don't cut in anymore you
have to show that there was an
interaction
well it's kind of like the guys that
pointed the finger at zuckenberg for
ripping off facebook i mean they still
probably got two three four hundred
million dollars
it was an undisclosed settlement but
they were able to prove this guy
took their platform and did something
else with it and that you have to think
of it the same way you have to have the
blueprints
for your work you have to have detailed
journal you have to have your
communications
and when they were what they were and
who they were with
so yeah and copyrighted with the library
of congress
so was that is that true that it's
easier for hollywood to just deal with
the lawsuit than pay
i think everybody likes dealing with a
lawsuit than going through the
the painstaking uh it seems everybody
today wants the easy way out
uh it's easy to rip off things it's too
easy to take advantage i know a very
prominent producer who since passed away
so i'm gonna tell the story without
mentioning a name
you know he found a script he was he was
a very successful producer
and he had been nominated for an oscar 3
and found a script
from an unknown writer who wasn't in a
wga or anything
and basically worked out a deal to pay
the guy
peanuts and wound up becoming a very
successful trilogy
and you know just bought and sold the
script over and over until he got it
where it needed to go and
you know it's it just seems like
hollywood's kind of
copying itself anyway i mean that's what
it does right every story has been told
it's how we tell it
you know shark movies are big right now
let's make a shark movie football movies
are big right now let's do a football
movie i mean you know i we capitalized
on that with great iron gang you know we
had we are marshall
yet invincible yet we are giants we're
facing the giants
yeah friday night lights it started it
so you had this movement of football
movies
and it's no different i mean that's just
what they do incidentally what's
interesting is the same guy who
took that script for peanuts it turned
out
admitted to me later he was trying to
make red iron gang with another studio
and he never had the rights to do it
so it goes to show you you know it's
people will just
easily take an idea and run with it and
yeah he never had the rights to do it
you know how do you feel when somebody
rips off your work it's i guess the old
saying is imitation is the greatest form
of flattery
but when you're reading the front page
of the trades and a big star is attached
to a project that you
walked into an agency or a network you
know
my dad always talks about how he had
brought in a uh
a script back in the in the early 70s
called special weapons assault tactics
and was told that's not for us and then
you know
years later
[Music]
so i uh i learned you know
be careful with your product but how
does it feel when you're ripped off it
it
it hurts because you have that it's
almost
you know it's like if you've ever walked
into your house after it's been robbed
it's the ultimate it's the ultimate
betrayal it's the ultimate form
of of uh you know
it's a violation i don't know why
somebody can't just say hey
kid you wrote a script it's pretty good
the idea is there
we want to take it and work we're going
to pay you i mean just the deception
that happens with these things and i i
can't emphasize enough that you have to
i mean it's it feels empty you look at
that time
and you most writers especially write
things on spec
because one day wouldn't it be great and
then one day you have a library of
scripts that you can look back and say
you have these 10 scripts but
each script takes time whether you're a
fast writer or slow writer i know people
that spend three months on a screenplay
i know people spend 10 years on a
screenplay i know somebody's actually
under 30th year on the same script
i cannot imagine if that got
ripped off i mean 30 years think about
it so
i tend to take things well that i tend
to take bad news well
so i didn't get all wrapped up in it i
just okay lesson learned chalk it up as
a life lesson and move on
did you get any compensation for a chain
i never got compensated
there are three projects that i did that
i created that got
taken um one was produced into a film
that never came out
the other one went into pretty hardcore
development at a major network with a
big star attached it never never did
come
um there was another one that
it was basically we had a pretty good
timeline and proof that there was there
was a ripoff
um and what was interesting is the the
the institution the studio whatever you
want to call it that did the ripping off
had also
optioned another project from us
previously so what they basically did is
they took
intellectual property that they had
optioned from us
and put it into another project a
storyline into another project that they
already greenlit
totally separate they were going to make
that anyway they were hoping to make
ours
ours didn't really come to fruition so
they kind of grabbed some stuff and
threw it in there
we hired the best of the best lawyers
and
they were unbelievable in how they
structured this case and their timelines
and at the end of the day nobody wants
to go to court nobody wants to sue
anybody
i'm a firm believer in the blacklist i
know people and i don't mean the script
side i'm talking about people saying
we're not going to work with him because
and it just got to a point where you
know other deals other options were made
hey
you know so do you get paid for it no
sometimes if it's handled in a certain
way and i think right you could
possibly uh you could you could
entertain another deal or two with
with a with an an institution that
would admit maybe they wronged you or
were upset you felt wronged
you know optioning another piece of
property for
two or three years isn't uncommon i
guess
if you play your cards right basically
what happened is they just said look you
know
all right we did what we did and you
guys want to go through a lot we're
going to bankrupt you in lawsuits it's
going to take 12 years today
do you have something else we can option
and you know they're not going to make
it but you know but that's how they do
it
i mean that's how that's how it worked
on the third on the first on the studio
one
yeah yeah they you know they'll come up
with creative ways to make you feel or
hey why don't we give you a development
deal no
not to pay anything they just take a few
gratuitous meetings with you over the
course of two years and you feel like
you got yours you know
interesting it's it's weird you know
it's it's a deceptive business and i
think that's what's driven me i'm
i don't i don't ever want to thumb my
nose at hollywood proper i've had a lot
of
success in it and thank god for it and
hope to work again in it i don't
count on it and i don't care if i don't
i went real rogue independent in what i
do because i just got tired of dealing
with a machine
i got tired of developing you know fall
in love with an idea
put it together whether you've got eight
dollars or eight hundred thousand
dollars and go do it what's stopping you
you know i mean the next film i'm doing
we're starting
in in a couple months and it it
started because a group of us were sick
and tired of sitting around during
covet and we figured we can toss 20 20
in the garbage
bin like a lot of people are or we can
show something we have something to show
for it
and it was kind of like we know two guys
with two great cameras and a sound guy
we got actors that want to play i got a
great writer who's got a ton of material
i'll direct produce and cut the thing
for free i don't care let's make this
year
something and then it turned into
something where investors have gotten
involved in
better actors and bigger actors and crew
and
now all of a sudden we have a real movie
we're gonna go make and it happened
because we just
got sick and tired of sitting around and
started putting things into motion we
never asked anybody for money
that was the last thing we just wanted
to get busy and have something to show
for 2020.
and the next thing you know we're in
full-blown pre-production on a show
you know so i think i like that
there's no development there's let's do
it
but how does a writer protect themselves
from getting taken advantage of
even though they have that they they
really want that
thing to pay off for them again i think
i think the most important thing a
writer can do
is obviously you have to copyright your
material and that includes the
treatments
it includes the script and i think you
have to take
you have to take notes of where projects
go um
you know i look back at some of the
projects i had ripped off and if i had
just
taken better notes just documented who
what when where and why
i could have stopped them from being
taken or at least gotten to partake in
its success or failure
from a producer or creator standpoint
and i just think it's too easy to
you know be people when we're coming up
we want
so bad to have our work accepted we want
to make it so bad whether we're an actor
or a writer
the problem is if you're an actor and
you want to make it you can audition you
can go out and meet people and do your
thing but
your only calling card as a writer is to
write and unfortunately
everything starts with the script you
don't have an actor attached you don't
have a producer
a director a set financing until what's
the script it's all about the script
so you're kind of kicking off the whole
project and the most valuable
thing that somebody can take is a script
it's the only thing they can take they
can't take an actor they can't take a
director
they can't steal a craft service person
they're going to steal the script
so you have to really think that you're
really the the lifeblood of a project
you are the inception
of the project and what you have is gold
to some people
so you have to protect it you have to
you have to take as much time as you've
taken
to write your script you have to think i
have to copyright it i have to copyright
every bit of
intellectual property that surrounds it
whether it's your beat sheets your
breakdown your
you know your boards whatever it is you
just you got to protect everything and
then you have to
really really be clear on who you've
given it to
why you're giving it to me and i also be
careful what you're giving it to you
know
hungry writers i can't tell you how
often well this this producer reached
out to me
on you know facebook and uh you know
they i sent them three of my scripts i
never heard from them again it's like
well okay did you look up who the
producer was well you know he
he had this ac credit on a film two
years ago and
you know look if if a real producer
wants to work with you they're not going
to
find you on facebook usually now i
understand that as a way to find people
but how did they find you on facebook
did they read something else you wrote
and
facebook was the only way to find you or
were they just trolling for people in
the writing
forums and the writing you know uh what
are they called the
the writing forms of facebook and that's
where a lot of these people get taken
advantage of
it's really easy all you have to do is
dm one writer who's writing something on
the board that you think is intelligent
gullible vulnerable and hungry enough
and just say hey
uh here's who i am i'm interested in
what you got i'd love to read your work
and
nine times out of nine they're probably
going to send it you know screen cap
those conversations get this guy's name
look them up
start a file on everybody you send stuff
to you should have a file on every
project
and a file on everybody who sees
whatever project you have
and that's a big way to protect yourself
a dossier
is that what that is i've heard new
words that's what the government does
what is there there's the dossier and
then there's the
uh what's the other one oped i've heard
these new words
since the last four years i never knew
before and in the reverse how can
someone who's been asked to read their
script vet
a producer so seeing just like
one credit on imdb with no picture no
contact info
very little online presence is that
someone who
you should really be sending your work
to i i always think it's important for
people to vet
on the other side is is you know we've
talked about before the easiest thing to
do
if you're a person who has a business
card that says you're a producer but you
haven't physically produced
uh the easiest thing to do is go to
something like facebook and find a
writer's form
and find people that are you know all
you have to do is join it's free to join
and you get to see the trends and habits
and some of the idiosyncrasies of the
people that are on that site
and you start realizing their
vulnerabilities their hopes their fears
their concerns and where
they are careless i find it
amazing that people will actually say
here's my latest script and throw it on
a facebook forum
and you go oh my god or a guy will say
hey i just did these 10 pages last night
would love feedback
okay um you know i think that's careless
um but you know
producers are predatory
by nature and sorry but they are that
you have something they want
so i think you need to protect your work
i think you need to
think twice before you just shotgun your
material out i think you need to look up
people
i still there's a lot of writers that i
respect that i know and i still try to
collaborate with that'll say oh i heard
from a producer
i sent this guy my work he reached out
to me and i'm looking i'm gonna go have
you
even oh no i know he doesn't have an
imdb presence or he doesn't even have
but he's you know and it's like not that
imdb is the
end-all be-all but good lord if somebody
has got
a history in the business of being
legitimate that's certainly one way to
better them
and i just it's mind-boggling how
how often people don't uh take the time
they don't want to hear the truth so
they just
they just shotgun it hoping that this
could be the one and i think they have
to be very careful hence you know
getting your
your projects ripped off several times
of your career because you're not
you know careful and i gave my projects
to
people that were real and legit but
i didn't protect myself and they know
when you don't
so even if someone's vetted
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
safe just because somebody's vetted
doesn't mean that you're safe i mean
you know easiest thing to do
is to get a script that's not copy
written
then have the power to make something
and get it from somebody who has no
cloud or juice or
voice or word uh in the industry
and if that's the case then what
what do they have to stand on if they're
not protected you know
so what if someone says well then maybe
i just shouldn't trust anybody
then why even then why even bother doing
this well you shouldn't you shouldn't
trust don't trust anybody
what you should do is protect your work
as we talked about before with the you
know united states copyright office
don't waste your time with the wga do it
with the usco
it's the same process kind of costs a
little bit more
but it's it shows people that are in the
know that you're serious
it shows that you know how to protect
your work and take copious
notes and you should have a file on each
project and you should have a file on
everybody that you send it to
that should be part of it and those
correspondences and if it's a phone call
take notes i talked to
shane stanley today it's october 1st
2020.
he said he wanted me to send a synopsis
emailed shane stanley at this email
address the synopsis for this story
waiting for a call back or a phone you
know an email and then when i email her
phone back
print it out put it in the file and that
way if i go off and make that movie
i've got it it's now the burden of proof
is on me that i didn't rip them off
it's always on the rider to prove that i
that i ripped you off but now all of a
sudden
if you do your due diligence it's now on
me to show that i
have to now provide all the stuff that i
did to develop the material
and that's harder to do do you do this
like in excel
or award pages what i usually do
is i have a backup email address like if
i have my company account whatever it is
dot com i have a yahoo account that i
don't access or give out to anybody
all it is is my overages it's every time
i email a project to somebody i bcc
it and then that way i have it safe
and then when that person replies i have
a folder on my main
of each project so every time i get a
hit so i'm getting
i got the send out sent somewhere else
and then i've got the reply and a whole
different other email mask so that way
god forbid one crashes one goes blank or
gets hacked i at least have half the
conversation somewhere
that's how i do it that's great we've
imagined that you've received your share
of screenplay pitches or you've heard
about
others pitching what are some of the
wrong ways
to pitch what are some of the wrong ways
to reach out to someone
i think there is a right way and a wrong
way to
present people your work your
screenplays to approach them i think if
you break it down
i think writers need to be just as good
if not better
as writing a synopsis or a treatment i
like getting those two page treatments
where you know if it's five acts it's a
paragraph per act
a title a log line a brief synopsis and
then the breakdown
i think if you can do that and you can
basically summarize what it is you're
trying to say i get
i can tell in two minutes that this is a
story i want to read i don't need to see
a script
but it's really important that you know
the craft of of writing too
because uh writing is a gift writing is
a craft
and a lot of people don't understand the
importance of good storytelling
and because they've spent a year and a
half writing a script doesn't mean it's
good and they have to respect a lot of
people
get hit with so many scripts that they
take it personally if you don't want to
read it and you know we all have lives
we're busy we have business life
personal life social life we have all
these things in our own work life
and i always you know if somebody is
kind
considerate and they reach out i always
try to say okay i won't look at a
synopsis but only if it's copy written i
need to see the copyright
you know registration receipt i'm not i
don't take anything without that
um so make sure you have your work copy
written
and be kind and considerate and
realizing that you're
you know you're you're not the only
person who has a script that needs red
and reading a script does take people a
couple of hours out of their day and
you know how many people do you know
that you don't know that would
take two hours out of the day for a
stranger to just read your script
so i just think it's about the
presentation it's about knowing how to
write
a synopsis or a treatment that can lure
a reader or a decision maker to want
to know more about what you're doing is
really important how often do you
receive
cold pitches uh you know it's not that
often
um i get i mean i get a lot of inquiries
which i really appreciate i don't mind
people asking i'm an open book you know
anybody can email me info
chainstanley.net i mean i don't care
it's how it's done
and it's for me
um when i just get an email that's
shotgun and i know it's shocked i even
look at it i just
you know i just write back and say i
don't accept unsolicited material and i
cc my lawyer
i cc my manager and i write them back
and i say hey you know you sent this to
me unsolicited i am not interested in
seeing this this is not how to do it
appreciate it if you have somebody who
who reps you if they want to reach out
to my manager or lawyer that's a
different story and i never hear back
from them again that's just the end of
it
people who reach out genuinely you know
because i do so much work with the
colleges that you know
i'll encounter a writer three years ago
and then they'll write
you know and say you know dear shane you
gave a workshop at my class in florida a
few years ago and you know i
finished a screenplay and i really
enjoyed your may i send it to you
i always write back and say i'm not
going to read your screenplay right now
but if you want to send me you know
copyright everything i go through
copyright everything i need to see that
it's been registered certified
copywritten with the usco
once that's done i will gladly look at a
treatment and we can go from there and
usually they're pretty cool about it i
don't mind reading those i don't i'm not
going to read scripts i just don't have
the time
and i know that's terribly heady to say
but i just don't i'm a slow reader
shane what are the top five reasons you
will reject a screenplay let's say it's
it's well written it's formatted but
there's just something that's not
working for you
you know when rejecting a screenplay the
first thing writers should never take it
personally
art is nothing but opinion i mean you
think about how many
great scripts got made years after the
fact
after they were turned down and rejected
by so many other filmmakers
it's about first and foremost it's about
the project connecting
with the person you're sending it to
just because i made a movie about
football
and had success with it doesn't mean i
want to make another movie about
football
i also want to evolve as a filmmaker so
what's important is is that you never
take it personally
um i would hope if i do read a script
and i think there's something there that
i would at least write
i would always try to make it a point to
write the writer or contact the writer
and say look i gotta be honest with you
you're talented
i like what you're doing i know somebody
who i think would appreciate it let me
help you
you know i have no problem with that and
one of the writers that i work with who
i
use one of my favorites to work with is
cj wally he's the the guy that has group
revolution
out of the uk and our relationship
kicked off by reading one of his scripts
that was
beautifully done i would never make the
movie i couldn't sell the movie but it
didn't mean he can't write
and i i read his words i read his the
his setups i read his
you know his character arcs and i just
and i read his theory on breaking down
scripts and doing proper treatments and
synopses and i this guy had it all
together
and for me it was like hey dude i love
your writing
i have a project i'm gonna do i want you
to write it and then we were able to
work together and like you know we've
written several scripts together
and that came because i read a script
that i i would never make
but i knew the writer was good so it's
not always about the script i don't
think spec scripts get made much anymore
filmmakers have an idea what they want
we have actors that we know what they
want to do
we have buyers and sales agents who we
know what they can sell at the moment
and we have an audience trend that you
know right now doing a drama
living in an apartment is not going to
sell we have all been locked in because
of covid for
six months in our four walls we want to
be outside we want to laugh i don't want
to hear about your problems i don't want
to think about my problems
so if we're selling scripts right now
and you're trying to pitch it better be
adventure it better be
funny it better have romance it better
get me out on the water i want it to get
me out in the desert i want to go on
travel these are the things that you
constantly have to think about
and writers don't writers are very
myopic
and that's okay we we get in a box
and it's all about this and you have to
realize there's there's actors there's
money that has to be raised there's
directors that have to come on board
there's um teams of people that have to
capture the vision to make this happen
and after all that's said and done is
can it be sold
are there those seven trailer moments in
this script that we know we can sell it
is there an uh an output
worldwide or is this just gonna appeal
to one place
and that's these are the things that a
lot of writers don't think about the
business
of the business it's not just whether
your script is good so much of it is
about
where is it going to sell you're still
selling a widget
are you selling a widget that only
appeals to one out of every
5 000 people or are you selling a widget
that everybody kind of needs
and that's how you have to look at it
when making a script
and what are those seven trailer moments
i don't think they're anything specific
i think they're the catch phrases
they're those
hero moments if you're telling an
actions right like you take any
two-minute super trailer that you see
and you'll see those five to nine
moments that you know are important in
the film they're the
the tent poles of the story they're the
catch phrases
they're that huge explosion they're that
great moment in the car chase
it's it's the sex scene real quick
it's the action running it's it's those
things
and they're not anything consistent but
your story has got to be able to tell
the executives who don't read scripts
and don't know much
it's got to tell them that i can sell
this that's all it is it's
can i sell it some of the relationships
i have with sales agents and buyers they
don't read the scripts they want the
synopsis
they want mock art you know they want to
see a mock poster that me and a writer
make and in two hours on photoshop and
say here here's your kind of idea for
the image here's your
here's your log line here's your title
and they'll tell you right then and
there yeah i can sell that
that's how these decisions are made
wow so so what why not even
forget the treatment why not just come
up with a great poster
and log well i think that's but you
still have to have a script to shoot
and finance so ultimately you're going
to need the script um
but i think i think that's all part of
the package because so many people are
from the filmmaker side i don't write as
much but if i have a writer who's done a
script
i expect the synopsis and the treatment
to be as good if not better than the
script it's got to be
because i know there's there's always
three scripts the one you write the one
you shoot and the one you cut
okay the treatment is what you're really
selling
overall they executives are not going to
read the script i deal with more
executives now they just want to see
they just want a two-page synopsis
and just show me some mock art so i know
what i'm selling and they'll tell you
well tell me in five minutes i can sell
it or you're gonna find somebody else i
can't do anything with this it's not my
wheelhouse okay
and then we make the decision do we do
we believe in this enough to roll the
dice and
struggle and pull teeth and try to get
it somewhere else or do we
listen to people we trust and say this
is not the one to do
that's our developmental process it's
very quick we don't go through the years
of development or months it's
here's an idea i'll pitch the idea
to my buyers if they like it i say okay
they like it let's do the synopsis and
then i get them the synopsis
sometimes with some mock art and then
they'll either say
okay the idea is good act two i can't
you can't do this in act two this
this i can't sell tweak it this way
and then they'll go you know in act four
can this happen maybe in act five it's
happening too soon or can you bring the
villain in sooner
those are the kind of conversations we
have and then it just the table is set
and the writer can go do it
and i the script the spec script is very
hard to sell i think spec scripts are
great calling cards if somebody can
write or not
found a tremendous writer through the
community college just
this during covid who i take a lot of
pride in i not only got her a manager
she got a job like writing a script
for hire for a very substantial
production company and this is one of my
zoom students
from the community colleges that reached
out to me
you were asking the right way and wrong
way she reached out to me she had taken
three or four of my zoom classes with a
community college
lovely woman very articulate kind
no expectations just i really appreciate
it i would love to share my work with
you
here's where i want to go in my career
and she's she's an older woman she's
like you know her son's like my age i
mean she's been around
and has worked around the industry but
never
really flourished as a writer
and i finally said let me know when
you're synonymous oh my god i know
somebody who's looking for this so i
said
i'm not going to read your script send
it to me i'll send it to somebody who
knows this company and the guy
read the script called me up and goes
who is this woman she's really good
and we got her an agent and three weeks
later she actually got a work for hire
on a greenlit film that they green they
had greenlit on the concept
and they liked her writing enough to say
you were you were a writer for hire on
this and she's on her last she's on her
second polish on it and they're getting
ready to go into production i think in
january
it's greenland how common is that
not very but i say that to inspire
because there are ways and again it came
from being kind it came from being a
familiar face it came from somebody who
who reached out with a tender heart and
a gracious heart
to understand and respect my schedule
and maybe i didn't want to read it
and understood when i said i don't want
to read your script but let me
let me look at the synopsis and then
when i was like there's something here i
said
i'm going to send a synopsis to somebody
i think would like this and if they do
i'm going to need you to have a script
ready and that's how it went
is synopsis king in this day and age of
instant information
and being able to get answers quickly i
suggest that it is definitely something
that is put to the forefront
uh going back to people's time and you
know we've developed this instant
gratification
generation of you know getting it on the
phone and i'll get you an answer let me
ask siri
i think a lot of us have put that into
our workflow um
i know what my days are i i hit the
ground i am working by 5
5 30 in the morning even when i'm not
making a movie and my wife is usually
saying all right honey come on it's
getting late you've been
you know this is when we're not doing a
movie i just i'm immersed in my work so
taking two hours a day to read a script
it doesn't fit i don't schedule read
days so
my my feelings if you want to write and
you want to get seen by filmmakers who
are busy and i suggest you really learn
how to build a treatment
besides being a good screenwriter learn
how to do a treatment learn how to do a
synopsis
um there is a a web platform based in
the united kingdom
called script revolution it was it was
it was created by cj wally
and i find if you're a writer i suggest
you go and check out
it's a free site it's it's it's i think
you will be blown away on
the the way it breaks down how to write
not only screenplay but the treatment
the synopsis the act breakdowns he's
created some you know the turn and burn
which is this
really cool theory and i think once you
understand that as a writer your
treatments are gonna
flourish which are going to make people
that are in a position of making movies
get more excited about what it is you're
doing and what you're trying to say so
i think the treatment and the synopsis
is so important the script ultimately is
but if i read a great synopsis and a
great treatment i will be more forgiving
on the script
knowing where ultimately this could go
where if i just get a mediocre script
and it's
okay and done i don't see the vision
that
you caught me in a page or two so i'm a
big proponent for the treatment
i'm sorry just real quickly what is the
turn and burn
that's a good question that's for him to
answer i mean if you go if you go on the
website if you go on to
scriptrevolution.com
there is a whole sub chapter about turn
and burn and it's his theory
on how he creates the synopsis and it's
a whole
it's a whole map of like 10 different
sayings that he has
that i could never relay i don't write
anymore
but it all makes sense and when i know
when i've collaborated with him or other
writers that are
part of his platform it's it's really
it's really about the developmenting the
treatment develop the treatment so the
script process is
is easy it's like as i talked about in
my book the most important thing about
filmmaking is the pre-production time
i i work myself to death during
pre-production so production is fun
and easy that's how it's supposed to be
you know pro football players will tell
you you work
monday through saturday and you get paid
to play on sunday
that's how it should be when you write
that's how it should be when you make a
movie and what they've done
at script revolution is they have
basically given you
training camp hell week and practice in
the
treatment side so the writing of the
script is actually
fast efficient and it's right on point
and there's no surprises
and that's what most filmmakers
development executives get concerned
about is writers going down rabbit holes
they weren't supposed to go down
going off track if your treatment is in
order
everything is it's expected you're just
filling up the pages
with witty dialogue with fun i'll give
you an example working on this film
we developed we've got a we've got a six
page treatment
that's the five acts it's the character
breakdown who everybody is what the
point of the show is what's the log line
what's the synopsis
we have gotten four acts in seven days
there's not been one surprise except
happy surprises because we all know
where this is there's four of us that
are involved in
doing the film that are from a
decision-making capacity not one of us
have been
thrown a bump a roadblock a speed bump
nobody's been like oh my god what's
going on and it was because the way the
treatment was handled going in
it's it's it is so paramount and
speaking of bumps i don't know if you're
reading my mind but i was just going to
bring up goosebumps
it's so funny that was the next thing i
was going to say was that r.l stein i
guess
the creative goosebumps he talked about
how he knows the ending
and he writes this treatment or whatever
and then once he knows the ending then
he can go back
and he can fool the audience and it's
it's effortless writing but it's just
getting that
that structure in place and i know and i
know in the way that they
do these treatments they often will have
17 blank pages and start on page 17 and
work backwards
it's not uncommon and it's interesting
and there's different ways for it to
work for everybody but it's kind of just
basically a way to think about it and i
think once you capture that
whether you're a writer or not you see
what he's doing oh i get it
and too many of us in the way i used to
write when i used to try to hack away
was i would just sit there and come up
with a title and write fade in and
tell my story sometimes i got lucky and
sold a few scripts i did okay
but as i got older my mind wasn't as
fast i wasn't as creative i had kind of
burned a lot of that creative energy
telling stories and then becoming a
filmmaker an editor a producer or
director
or i wasn't just sitting for weeks at a
time writing
so i learned later in life how important
a treatment is
it's it's so important to know what it
is you're going to do
and it's great when you can surprise
yourself as a writer but
to know where you're going to know the
purpose of each scene to know
the arcs and the back stories that
aren't going to be on the page of each
character i think if you as a creator
know all that you'd be amazed the
stories that you can tell it's just it's
just smooth sailing
shane we've heard you say send us
treatment we've heard on our side people
say
okay i sent them a treatment it was a 20
page treatment is that okay
is that too long oh i think in first
pass i think i think you need to again
be considerate
of the reader when i say send a
treatment
i would like a title i'd like to know
who it was written by
i'd love to see a log line and then i'd
like to see a two-page
synopsis give me a paragraph per act
that's it
that's all i need and i could either say
yeah i like this i want to see a script
or i could say you know what
if you have a more in-depth treatment
breaking down some things
back story on the characters cast size
i'd love to see it that 20 then i would
expect that
10 to 12 to 20 page treatment it's not
that you shouldn't have them i feel when
i say you need to be versed as a writer
in writing synopsises and treatments
those are two separate things that are
equally as important
because i'm only going to read a
synopsis first i just want to see a page
or two on what you're doing
and if that instills not quite enough
interest to see the script but i'm
intrigued enough to say i want to know
more
that's when that 20-page treatment or
whatever it is that you've done
is important obviously not a 90-page
treatment then just send me the script
but
you know what i mean it's it's i think
the synopsis is king it's it's just
let's let's ignite that fire spark the
interest and if you get that
have the treatment ready but hopefully
the script is there and tight
good that was a great question because
it is because
some people send you like a paragraph
you're like that's it
you know i always say here's an option
should just be a paragraph per
you know treatment is a paragraph per
act and then the breakdowns anything but
a synopsis should be about a page and a
half
two pages and and if you need more than
that to tell the story
you gotta you gotta relook at your story
it's too confusing it's too
it's too long it's too you know it's too
hodgepodgy you gotta
tighten it up what if someone doesn't
know
the difference between a synopsis versus
a treatment i think a synopsis versus a
treatment
a good answer at least that that i can
give and
what i see it as a synopsis is usually
a paragraph or two you know a thousand
words or less
is kind of it's going to tell me what
this is now a treatment
usually is going to have a log line it's
going to have
what the tonality is it's going to have
the purpose it's going to have the
message
and then it's going to give me five acts
and it's a paragraph or if it's three
acts it's gonna be a paragraph
per act and then it's gonna talk about
the characters it's gonna break them
down as if you would see
in an actor's breakdown it's gonna say
you know uh
karen age 25 comes from humble
comes from humble beginnings loves cats
it's got a wonderful husband you know
and those are the kind of things you
don't see in a synopsis as much as you
know
karen mid 30s oh i just added 10 years
but
i think i think a treatment is more a
real breakdown of developmental notes
tonality purpose where this can go
and all the possibilities like one thing
that they do in
in what script revolution teaches is um
alternative endings i always like when
they break something down for me
and i've got the five acts i've got the
tonality i've got the this and that
and then all of a sudden it says
alternative endings and it says
this first what we went with and then it
gives four or five alternative endings
that are completely different that still
fit and why you could or couldn't use
them it's just really to me it's really
fleshing out your story as a writer
and giving people different different
perspectives of how it could
go you know we've all heard about
alternative endings and seeing
the fun dvd bonuses where this movie had
three different endings like i
understand castaway had three different
endings that they shot
well obviously those were written and
that was an option it was something that
was on the table
well the writer gave that gift to the
filmmakers and the filmmakers ultimately
decided to go with the one where he's at
four corners and
the welder who he left the package for
came up and told him which way to go and
she just went and we never know if he
followed her or not
but there were three endings apparently
and
i'm sure that the treatment probably
talked about those opportunities
do you think you've run out of ideas you
said just
you know as time's gone on just you've
told so many stories and you've made so
many films and things
do you think someone runs out of ideas
oh
i don't think i would i would hate to
think people run
out of ideas if you have found a niche
and you flourished in a niche and done
the same
style over and over and over again i
think you got to be careful not to try
to become a one-trick pony
um i've done different kind of films in
my career i've done the dramas i've done
the rom-coms i've done the actions i've
done the thrillers i've done the
suspense i've done
you know i enjoy the action thrillers
a little bit more as i get older i'm
gearing more toward doing those
especially the female driven action film
is really where i'm
focusing the next chapter of my life um
adventure romance you know adventure
romance stories are fun too
um i think what's important is to
collaborate with people that
inspire you um i don't write anymore but
i know i'm good at ideas and i know that
from the writers that i collaborate with
they said oh no you've given me
something i can run with this and that's
all i'm responsible of is all i can say
is hey
here's some here's a story i want to
tell does that do anything for you and
they either
catch the vision or they don't um i
think every story has been told it's how
we tell it that makes it fresh right i
mean
you know everybody's seen mob movies
everybody's seen action movies
everybody seen you know the harry met
sally knock-offs and the scream
knock-offs i mean it's all been done
what what twist are you gonna put in
there what what
originality or flair are you gonna what
wrinkle are you gonna put in the story
that's gonna make
audiences engage and not feel that
they've seen this
over and over again i think that's
important
when you start thinking about the
structure of a story key beats
turning points you know i think um
i think you need to keep a reader
engaged i don't think there is a set
time but if you're you know 15 18 20 25
30 pages in and we still have no idea
what's going on
or there hasn't been that you know
moment
i i think you kind of need to rethink
some things
um you know there's the old saying when
you watch a movie it's that 42 to 46
minute point that usually
kind of becomes a slow burn no matter
what the movie is so i know a lot of
writers and filmmakers try to make sure
that point of the film
doesn't lack a spark or an interest
because that's
a lot of times where people they're not
going to give up on the film but they
tend to get a little restless
it seems a lot of people take a really
long time to get to the point and i
think and i've learned that
as a independent filmmaker when you sell
your material
it's more about you know we have to
remember this as a business and now in
days with phones and tablets and
distractions and pets and kids and
everything else under the sun going on
we're constantly
interrupted audiences when they see your
film
unless they're really at a movie theater
and truly turn their phones off
are never really 100 immersed in your
story
there's always something there's a noise
outside there's a cat knocking over a
vase
it's a kid who's crying because he
didn't get his way and he's hungry and
you know you have to realize that as a
filmmaker
what you're up against and i think
to just kind of lull along to tell your
story
it's very rare that you're going to be
able to compete with anything so i think
to be able to throw some twists and
turns
to engage your audience into some new
layers or elements or characters
or what's the point of this movie a
little sooner than we used to i think is
happening
needs to happen more often and i think a
lot of writers are starting to figure
that out
so then you wouldn't be working some of
this out in the treatment stage
it's once you actually start the actual
screenwriting process
i've gotten to the point now when i work
with writers i tell them it's got a you
know it's it's sadly
um there's kind of an 11-minute rule
abroad
that we kind of need to know what this
is about what's going on what we're
signing up for in the first 11 minutes
of the actual movie
which is going to tell somebody that's
got to happen in the first 12 to 15
pages of the script
um and i don't like telling stories that
way but i've also learned the hard way
i've had some some projects that
you know hey if you do this it'll sell
hey
if you change this it will it will move
and
what i've learned is the faster we get
to the point in our storytelling and i
know this goes against everything from
telling great stories of the old days
but we're living in a new
time and it has really gotten to be
about get to the freaking point
what am i signing up for early they they
want to know it's like you know give an
example in the film that i
just did that's coming out break even
it's about four kids who find
50 million dollars while scuba diving at
a remote island
and we developed this opening and this
whole thing
and this back story and why are these
kids here and who are they and what's
their relationships
and it was basically yeah we need to
find out
50 million dollars by 12 minutes in it's
like well wait a minute that doesn't
come in until page 30. well
it needs to come in about 12 minutes in
so you
you have to restructure some things you
have to cut scenes you have to cut
backstory because at the end of the day
when you're selling a movie
around the world they're signing up for
something and if you're selling an
action film if you're selling a thriller
if you're selling a suspense story
you better get to it because there's too
much competition there's too many things
that are moving
fast that'll hold the tension because it
moves so fast that's where that mtv
generation of cutting came from is we
don't know how to tell a good story so
we're gonna cut a bunch of stuff really
fast so you're afraid to take your eyes
off the screen and that has
now become it's found its way i think
it's found a balance in storytelling
with films
a little better but we need to get to
the point and if you look at the older
films
uh some of the most of the ones that i
grew up you know cherry it's a fire the
black stallion you know all these
enchanting april you're looking like 25
28 35 minutes in until you really kind
of have an idea
if you watch the black stallion they
don't in introduce
mickey mickey rooney's character until
about
i think 48 minutes in you know the kids
alone at the island for 30 minutes are
crying out loud then he gets home and
he's got to reintegrate in school and
then all of a sudden the horse runs away
and then he goes on this trip to try to
find the horse and then there's your
co-star
and it was also that way with on golden
pond they didn't bring
you know jane fonda in until 25 minutes
in
so i don't think those play as much
anymore
not saying the films don't hold up is
great cinema but
we want to meet the players we want to
know what the game is a lot quicker now
or even the stepford wives like i mean
that was
like the original the original one yeah
i mean just long
driving scenes with the music the
soundtrack and yeah
there was something comforting about
that i don't know if that would work
today
well you know quentin did it in once
upon a time in hollywood i think he
really exploited the driving scenes
but we're looking at the back of brad
pitt and leonardo dicaprio's head so
you know that makes it a little
different but what i try to tell the
independent filmmakers if you're not
getting brad or leo as your stars and i
don't even get them as my stars
um your your international buyers want
to get to the point
and we're at a point now where we you
know we are able to lock
picture and we don't make different cuts
for different markets or parts of the
globe we've kind of learned that
what what works comfortably everywhere
you know there's 54 territories that we
sell to
around the globe 100 what is it 170
countries and
in that you you have 54 territories
and you want to try to do something
that's going to appeal to everybody and
it's hard to please all the people all
the time but getting to the point
quickly is one that you can
really help sell that movie a lot better
if people know what they're signing up
for in the first 15
20 minutes tops well it's interesting
because people seem to get upset when we
say
that or we interview people and they say
you know if a script isn't good by
10 pages in most people will stop
reading it
and so then the comments are well you're
not giving it a chance
right people just don't have the
patience anymore you know again i hate
to revert to it you go back to i mean
look at close encounters of the third
kind
brilliant film that is a slow burn
i think if that movie was made today
that would be a lot different
not taking anything away from steven who
did a great job writing the script it
was based on an experience he had as a
kid
and a great job directing it but you're
going to tell me that movie today would
play
at that pace i don't think so and you're
right
a lot of people you're not giving it a
chance and most readers will say god if
it doesn't get me by page eight i'm done
i think you kind of have to you know the
executives
you know there was a trend where all the
executives are saying you got to find
that hook it's got to be edgy you know i
want it to be edgy and grab me you know
shake me by my
by my lapels by page eight you know and
so everybody came up with the edgy crazy
opening that just shocked everybody
i don't think i don't think shock and
awe is what make people watch a whole
movie
people want to be drawn in they want to
care about characters they want to go
along for a journey and they know what
they're signing up for but you have to
make that journey interesting you want
to put some bends in the road
you want to have some interesting things
that they're going to pass and
i think you need to occasionally give
them a flat tire throw a rod in the
engine
they're going to have to get out grab
their bags hitchhike find a ride
you know i think i just think that's
where we are now people are just so
bored i mean you look at twitter twitter
has an auto feed now
i don't even i can't even go on it
anymore because the second i try to read
what somebody tweeted it automatically
scrolls
and i can't find the tweet i was reading
and there's no way to stop that that's
just how we're getting our information
now
and there's we gotta find a balance in
storytelling
but that is kind of what what's working
right now
and it's frustrating it's a hard pace to
keep up with
how do you write good dialogue i think
the best dialogue comes from the best
listeners
i had an absolute crash course in
writing dialogue
years ago i used to write with charlie
sheen
i don't care if they don't credit him
and the sitcoms he's been in as a writer
i know who's been writing the dialogue i
worked with him for three years
i i never read or heard better dialogue
from anybody than that came from him
that he wrote
and i asked him one day i used to be
really good at writing scene direction
my dialogue was flat it wasn't
interesting it wasn't engaging it was an
edgy or seat
and i asked him one day when we were
writing
the way we worked is we'd set it up and
i would write the scene direction and he
would do the dialogue unless you know
it was some basic stuff it was easy and
i finally said to him i said
where do you get this encyclopedia of
incredible dialogue
i've never heard anybody with it before
and he said
you just listen he said you know
when this was working these aren't
working and if these aren't working you
can't absorb what's happening
and how people interact and find those
gems he said
most most of the things that i write
that people like
i heard at a party i heard at a barbecue
i heard at an airport i heard
while i was pumping gas he said you know
i'll get out and pump gas
and i'll hear a couple bickering in the
car next to me at the pump
and he said that's gold he goes that is
gold man he said you know and this is
before everybody had phones we were we
weren't listening to them we were doing
this
so i find the best
the best advice to writing a dialogue is
listen put yourself in a character's
position that you've created
you know it goes back to the old um i
think
keeping an audience interested in good
dialogue i think
also the problem is a lot of people try
to outwit themselves with dialogue
they think they've got to use verbage or
words that people don't use
they got to show you how smart they are
i think we've talked about it before
it's like the drummer that overplays
everything to show look how good my
chops are
and it's not about that it's it's about
it's about making things sound organic
and that's a lot of things that the
actors have to understand too is you
know they're acting or are they
truly listening and responding with the
work
but i think the best dialogue comes from
the best listeners and the people that
know how to implement those words that
they've discovered over the years and
new
in new arenas i mean obviously you're
not going to be pumping gas at a gas
station and you're a husband and wife
every script you write is not going to
be about a husband and wife pumping gas
at a gas station so where else can you
implement that could that be
a film like sahara where matthew
mcconaughey and penelope cruz are
walking across the desert
or you can put some of that bickering in
different situations but it's
how you use it how it inspires you to go
down different paths
that's how i've i i learned from him to
to
write better dialogue i'm still not very
good but
i know i i know good dialogue when i
hear it and i'm good at adjusting
dialogue when i get it
and i it's about listening and now
people are on
phones so you can just hear one side or
one side
and i don't think people realize or they
care
how well you can hear them and how
dialed in everybody no pun intended to
the people are
to what i mean i've heard some major
arguments major personal
and i'm like i don't think this person
realizes i can hear them halfway across
the store
but that's gold too it's gold and it's
even better when they're
when they're on speaker phone so you do
get to hear all of it or they're the
receivers up so loud but you're right i
mean sometimes you'll hear one half of
the conversation and sometimes that
could be
better because you're able to imagine i
mean can you imagine if it was hey
harold you didn't take the trash barrels
in and that's what the whole fight's
about but you're only hearing harold's
side
can you imagine what you can create mod
is yelling
to him about i mean
when you were working at the car lot
did it did you pick up anything about
dialogue i realized that's not why you
were there
but if i'm coming to look at a car
you know i'm probably going to be
hesitant i'm probably going to be like i
don't want this guy to sell me anything
but i do need a car but i don't want to
let him know that
sure so i'm going to be very selective
with what i say
i learned as i said when the owner of
galpin had said come sell
cars he said you'll learn more about
life than you've ever known and it'll be
the education that you lacked he wasn't
he wasn't kidding
you become a good listener because you
have to overcome all objectives you have
to address every concern and need that a
customer has
so how does that happen it happens by
listening and
i always i it wasn't dialogue lines i
don't think
and i have a very retentive memory if i
hear something i remember it
um there wasn't anything said
in those 18 months i worked there that
stood out but it was
mannerisms it was quirks it was
character flaws or
or neat things about
people that i that i still to this day
will implement in my characters
the way a husband and wife interact it's
not about what's said it's about how
it's said it's about the posture
it's about um
the the 45 year old son who's with the
70 year old parents buying the ford
taurus today
and you realize the parents have a
gambling addiction they're getting a car
to drive to vegas
every other week but the 45 year old son
still lives at home to help supplement
the
the overhead so they can afford to
maintain their lifestyle and the kids
kind of a deadbeat too i mean
there's all sorts of and then you look
at that and you go well that's that's a
story
you know you got this retired this
retired milk man
and his wife who ran a salon and now
they are addicted to going to vegas
every well what else are they doing when
they go to vegas that we don't know
about you know
and then your minds are what do they see
on that trip to vegas um
you know it's the the lotto winners i
sold i sold to a few lotto winners
that was interesting i actually had a
salesman i worked with
who had won 24 million dollars in the
big lotto
and he left his wife and
two and a half years later he was at the
point selling cars with me
and you want to talk about like having
it all and losing it and you know
friends who
abandoned him when the money was gone
and he said yeah you know it's funny my
wife still has her 10 million
you know and here i am selling cars
trying to make trying to make a living
living in a one-bedroom apartment you
know and
he was the one who left her and was
horrible to her yeah
you see a whole bunch of really
interesting
um but that two years sorry to interrupt
but that two years
was probably very fascinating it was
fascinating as i said i'm still
very close to the family that that
gifted me that opportunity the bachmanns
i am still very close to some of the
salesmen that i worked with a lot you
know sadly some of them have perished um
you know some of the people that were in
that sales class i took patrick wellman
just died six months ago i found out and
stuart sank who sold with me and i got
the most
character stories out of the anybody in
the world
passed uh these would be who i worked
with and i i was very close to and
um it was amazing uh just the people the
experiences the
the encounters of just walking out
having a cigarette
and encountering a guy whose car is in
for an oil change and that 20-minute
exchange you have with this guy
those conversations will live with you
forever but you don't have to sell cars
to do it you can
you can drive an uber you can work at a
restaurant as a waiter you can work
anywhere
most of the encounters that i've had in
my life that i write about are about
personal experiences or exchanges or
encounters that i've had
anywhere but it's funny you bring up the
car years because that was my job five
six days a week i'd spent those eight to
twelve hours a day
at the dealership dealing with no two
days were ever the same
fighting between you know salesmen for a
customer
or customer you know there's an old
saying and buying cars is all buyers are
liars
and it was about trying to i learned
something um we used to have a salesman
there that sold
ungodly amounts of cars and made ungodly
amounts of money
and i used to say to him what's your
secret and he says you just got to
remember all buyers are liars
and they're telling you one thing
because they think they can have an edge
and the
secret to successfully selling cars is
giving buyers
they got to trust you they got to like
you and want to deal with you but he
said
you have to let them think they have
control but they really don't have an
ounce of it and it's almost like being a
film director
actors love to be directed and
controlled
but they also like to think that they
they're the show they're
and as a good director will help steer
them and let them think that they can
run with it
and you got to be able to rein them in
without them knowing you're being reined
in
it's an art it's a dance and it's that
way selling cars
um but it taught me how to negotiate
selling cars and negotiating
four five six times a day sure taught me
how to go out and raise money sure
taught me how to negotiate
with contracts and actors and agents
it's the same thing how much for how
much
right so that's
everybody should go sell cars and you'll
become a better filmmaker
[Laughter]
what's the best screenplay someone's
ever submitted to you
best screenplay somebody's ever
submitted to me
wow um i've been fortunate to read some
good ones
i mean um you know i got a script
i got a script called chase the sunset
from cj wally years ago that
that's what turned me on to work with
him it was just again it was a film i
couldn't
really make but it was
just it was just really good and then i
was sent a script
by nicole fair fair brother
a while back and it was a love story
called the one
and it was just a beautiful pure
coming-of-age story for a married woman
who realized she had she was in a
situation that wasn't healthy it wasn't
an abusive relationship it was a loving
marriage it was complacent marriage
but it was a dream of hers to be a
writer and
she wanted to put a toe in the water
in the writing world and how her writing
was accepted
and the doors that opened to her and it
was told from a woman's point of view it
was just a beautiful story and it was
you know occasionally you find these
gems that come your way that you don't
expect they're happy surprises
where you you read it and you say god
someday it would be great to have the
power to just
give everybody the middle finger and
make it and who cares if it should or
couldn't be done and when i say it
can't be done or i couldn't do it it's
because we have
people that we're beholden to that write
checks to make movies they expect
films that are going to be marketed and
marketable and going to
work in certain markets that pay a
certain amount and you just know
sometimes reading a script this is not
going to work
but boy it's you know sometimes you try
to work with the writer and say can we
finagle it a little here and finagle a
little little there and see if we can
and
sometimes the writers are so hell-bent
on the vision of the story
they say no and they say i don't care if
it never gets made
it's going to stay the way it is or
never get made and i i have a lot of
respect for that
i really do um those those two were real
special
when you say give the middle finger and
i realized you're just using this
metaphor but
what does that entail like what does it
really mean are you really are there
people actively stopping the production
or
no what it means is is you know i'm very
fortunate i
i work with backers who don't read
scripts they don't know or care who's
in them they don't ask um
it's usually a synopsis a page
a paragraph this is what it's about
here's some teaser artwork to kind of
give you an idea of the world
and we'll usually just photoshop a one
sheet and say this is the idea
this is it how much do you need this
much okay
and they trust me and know that this is
something that'll sell around the globe
and that they're gonna they're gonna
make their investment back hopefully
plus
and it makes sense um when i say give
the middle finger
giving the middle finger would be
knowing i'm asking an investor to sign
up for something that the chances are
very slim they're going to see their
money back because it's not a marketable
product and also knowing that my sales
reps
fortunately we have a good relationship
they'll take it on but i know
i've kneecapped them because i've given
them this as a story to sell
you know what i mean there's there's
that well you know
okay well you're gonna kill half the
territories are not gonna buy it
and instead of getting fifty thousand
dollars for a
three-year license in in spain they're
going to give you eight thousand dollars
for
five years is that really what you want
well that's not fair to your investor
but hey it's art and you know when i say
to give the middle would be nice to be
in a position where
i don't care i'll write the check or i
have an investor we've had so much
success
they're begging for a loss maybe this is
the one you know and
it does happen it's it's it's hard
nobody wants to go into fail
but there are some stories that are some
of the best scripts i've ever written
and it doesn't matter
who stars in them or how who does them
you just know that this is not a
marketable
product but god it's good it's a story
that needs to be told
especially when you come out of
something like cobid we've all we don't
as we talked about we don't want drama
right now dramas are tough cells abroad
you know they're really tough and
they're tough anyway
but right now they're extra tough but
the best the best scripts i've written
are drama
dramas are tough to sell because of
everything
you know we've experienced especially
now they're they're especially
they're especially tough but i'd say the
best scripts i've ever read are dramas
would you consider making a feature
length film for ten thousand dollars
right now
i've made a feature length film for ten
thousand dollars
i've made a a 48-minute pilot for 500
uh budget's never an issue for me um i
think we talked about recently
uh coming out of this year and what a
horrible disappointment it's been i
think for everybody
um licking our wounds you know the great
losses we've had i think it sadly
started with kobe and then neil pert
from rush and then just went into covet
and just
crashed and burned and just kept burning
um
uh yeah we're at that point where i
think the next one uh just to keep the
risk factor down and just to get out and
shake the dust off i mean we're not
going to spend 10 grand but we're going
to keep the budget low and go out and
have some fun
i would do something for 10 grand
tomorrow absolutely i would
i hope i elaborate on that and i just
it's a yes or no yeah of course i mean
that's where
you know that's where i started you know
my first my first short was
i was told i'd have 25 000 to make it
and by the time we rolled camera i had
five grand
you know what happened to the rest of
the money oh you know
you know oh i got 25 grand i'll
give you 25 grand let's go make this and
well i've got five
okay so is that your litmus
if they tell you to subtract what like
70 percent
i don't work that way anymore i was
young and it was my first directory
director job and you know i had a script
and it was
with uh a group of people i wanted to
work with and somebody came to me and
said i want to finance
you know one of your projects and i was
like great and they said i'll give you
25 grand and to me that was a lot of
money
i knew what i could do with 25 grand and
we we
went the first day and i was told after
we were two hours in oh by the way
i was only able to come up with five
grand oh i still gave them the same film
they would have gotten for 25
but you know i still got an academy
award-nominated actor
that's great i did it for five yeah so
i'm all for those no-budget films i love
it
what's the lowest budget you would
consider i i never consider a budget i
to me look you're either going to get
paid or you're not i
don't do shorts because they take as
much time and energy
they just they're just longer on the
screen you still have to pre-produce
them you still have to
cast them you still have to hire a crew
you stop feed people you still have to
get locations you still have to
put gas in cars so you know the first
the first thing i ever did
i did a 46 minute pilot
for 500 bucks and
somebody came to me once and said you
did that for 500
it's 48 minutes why don't you make a 90
minute movie for a thousand dollars
and i wound up getting like 10 i think
10 or 12 to do it
but we did it and it was fun and
um you know you grow i mean you make
your projects to grow but sometimes the
right thing comes along and
when you get to the point you are in my
life where where i'm at it's you're
there you're gonna make money doing this
or you're not are you doing it for the
money
don't do them if you're doing them
because you want to stay relevant you're
doing it because you want to keep the
muscles tone
because you believe in something or
someone or you just want to like right
now we've been indoors for five and a
half months i
i'll go pay to work right now i mean i
just want to get out of the house and
yell action and cut and argue with an
actor and yell at a dp about something
or a pa for wearing a red shirt
i don't care you know for me it's just i
mean i've literally been sitting on my
ass for five and a half months now we've
been very productive
but i still have been sitting on my ass
for five and a half months so
do i want to sit at home and not make
money or do i want to go out and
have some fun with people i care about
and create and have something to show
for the year so there's there's no
limits on budget or
any of that for me it's just go how much
you got what do you want to make let's
do it
that's how i work what are some of the
things that independent filmmakers skip
over
thinking oh i don't need to spend a lot
of money on that but actually
that's dangerous for them to do that you
know i always say there's five things
that really make a film look
low or no budget and it's it's
cinematography
it's the sound it's the actors you
choose
it's the editing and it's the locations
and if you can step up in those five
arenas and get the best
that you can and then really try to get
better
you're gonna you're gonna have a project
that is just a step above
you know i spent a lot of years judging
different film festivals
um obviously the workshops and things
that i do with different schools so i i
see it all and when you start a film and
it's
shot just so bad
and there's no thought to framing or
composition
or anything it's it's just you're done
and the sound it's bad sound
is is so easy to get and it's one of
those things that
i i watch more people chance on and
getting a good sound
uh sound recording uh on the set
everybody likes user friends and lovers
and their movies chances are your
friends and lovers are not good actors
there are so many
film schools there are so many acting
classes that you can call
and say i'm doing a student project i'm
doing a spec
film i want actors that are good and
know their craft and you know what they
will
sign up to do it because they need tape
you you ask your girlfriend or your
friends either because you're afraid to
ask real talent and they may not like
your work or want to do it and that's
where you're wrong
or b because you're afraid your
girlfriend will leave you if you don't
put her in your movie
and that's you know i read about that in
the book um it's kiss to death i mean if
your girlfriend's a good actor
give her a roll but i would be very
careful
in in casting and editorial is important
um you know editing is everything
i i spent many years in the edit bay
before i considered myself a filmmaker
and i
i learned what not to do in the edit bay
and it really
it makes me sad when people i think
about his writing or their their
cinematography real
or you know the end result without
thinking about the most important result
in the filmmaking process which is
really the editorial
and also the cinematography i think they
work very much hand in hand
locations are key because anybody can
shoot in their house
anybody can shoot in their kitchen
anybody can shoot in their car
our job as storytellers to take people
places where they can't go
where they wish to go or where they're
afraid to go
and if you give them locations that are
just you know
interesting and break break the monotony
of every other
low-budget film i think you'd be
surprised how much more
success you can have with your film you
know i i had a wonderful drama teacher
and i i always
quote him mr kilpatrick from high school
and his favorite saying was come up with
three ways to do something and go with
the fourth
and i wish i remember that more often
i'd probably have better movies that
were more successful
if i did but especially young filmmakers
you know hey i could shoot this at my
house
okay scrap that there's one idea you're
not doing it i can shoot it in my garage
okay that's even worse it's still at the
house but no you're not gonna do it
shoot it in the car why you know does
i'm all for
keeping dialogue scenes moving so
putting them in a car is a good way to
do that
but where can you do this that's
different that's just going to make the
viewer feel like they're watching
something fresh
and i think locations are key the most
important thing
is um you know where people put money
where they shouldn't is it seems to be
the wrap parties
i i'm a i'm a big anti-wrap party guy um
it's just money that's never going on
the screen it's money that
you're more interested in the social
media aspect of people
cooing over your your you know
your wrap party and i think it's
important to have a gathering of the
people that have worked hard for the
film but do it
smart it's like when we do a film we try
to
schedule our biggest cast days on the
last day
and something centrally located so
people who aren't involved in the last
day can come visit the last day
and we'll spend a little extra money on
the catering
we may go and buy 10 bottles of
champagne for the day
not expensive ones but and put
a simple day for the last day so we can
end early
no stress and then party right there we
don't need to go rent out bowling alleys
we need to go rent out you know
all these places it's just money that
doesn't go on the screen and when you're
making especially independent films
every dime counts why are you gonna blow
it in one night that's never gonna go on
the screen think about it
i know people that have spent 25 grand
on a film
and they'll spend five grand on a wrap
party and i'll watch the film and say
why didn't you get a real editor we
couldn't afford one really
you know you could have gotten so and so
for three grand to do that
look at so-and-so's resume oh they've
cut 15
studio films that went number one
they've cut 18 sitcoms that are like
tier sitcoms that on their off time will
happily moonlight and gladly
get involved and get their hands dirty
for fun for a little money
and that's always the excuse well we
couldn't afford it but it's always
something else that they can afford that
just doesn't matter and i think they
just have to re-prioritize
sadly i think social media has become
the driving force but behind what people
do
i look i know when i'm shooting a movie
18 months later when the movie comes out
nobody's going to care about our set
pitch look people want to post on
instagram
and facebook hey we're on set look at us
great it's not going to sell one
ticket it's not going to sell one dvd
it's not going to get one download it's
about how you build up
to the end and its release and there's
something you don't want to give us you
know you don't want to give people
overexposure you don't want to make
people punch drunk on your pictures of
the same same same with no results or no
output you know so we try to be very
careful when we
promote our films and not do it for
years of social media hype and
likes it doesn't sell any movies it's
not going to work
i want to go back to something that you
said that was really interesting you
said you wrote about it in your book
and that is using a girlfriend you could
also fill in
boyfriend family member co-worker cousin
right
whoever um how do you have that
conversation with that person because
you know you want to keep the
relationship with the person or maybe
you don't but
let's suppose you do want to keep the
relationship how do you
say listen do you audition them the way
everyone else does
i think it's a lose-lose i say if you're
a young filmmaker don't date an actor
i'm married to an actor um and we have a
great relationship she did four years on
general hospital she's been in a lot of
fun movies and
there's never a person like for me i
always try to put my wife in and and
just have her there to be a ball but she
produces with me she's involved in the
post-war we work on a film together for
eight to twelve months
having her be a part of it on camera is
something i like to
let her flex that muscle and have fun
and she's good she knows her crap she's
good at what she does
but she doesn't have expectations for me
either she understands it's a business
i don't like having her in front of the
camera
as a director i just i i i
am not as gracious with her as i
probably could be i could be better as a
husband to a wife who's acting
um and that's just probably my fault
it's just you know i
i just it's not a dynamic that i love
but we found a way to make it work and
she's been in every film i've done over
the last
15 20 years and it's worked but
um to get back to your question i think
you have to decide are you
in this to showcase a whole bunch of
friends or are you here to make a career
and if you're going to become a doctor
you're going to become an architect
if you're going to become a lawyer are
you going to spend all those years in
college and bring your friends along
with you
while you're studying taking your tests
and learning the craft of medicine i
don't think so so
i think filmmaking communities are
important and yes relationships build
you're going to meet women in film
school or actors on the set that you're
going to fall in love with
but i think you really have to think
above the shoulders and think what is
what is
the purpose of this project and what do
i hope to gain out of it and selfishly
you have to build what's best for the
project there's nothing harder
than when you've got somebody you love
who's in front of the camera that is
just atrocious and they just sink the
ship
what i always try to do coming up is i
would
i would find ways to utilize people's
gifts in ways that
wouldn't sink the ship you know i always
say to somebody well
you want to work in the industry anyway
if you weren't going to act what else
would you want to do
well you know why don't you produce this
with me i need somebody to handle sag
paperwork i need somebody to handle our
locations
and then you know what throw them in
under five throw them something
expendable or if god forbid it's awful
get rid of it and i'm sorry to talk so
so straight the only way to get rid of a
problem is to not have a problem
or to be able to get yourself out of a
problem and if you know you're starring
your
girlfriend who can't remember a line or
hit a mark or understand the
the craft of the the respect the craft
of acting enough
to know it why are you wasting your time
it just doesn't make sense i i don't
have much much
grace or uh i'm not very soft harder
when it comes to that i say just don't
even don't even go there
yeah i think it's not just girlfriends
though i think if there's friendships
that are built around you know people
whatever it is being in films together
that's great and i think it could just
be a really difficult
thing for people to handle yeah i mean
ed burns was very lucky with brothers
mcmullen i mean he had some very
talented friends
but i mean you know that happens once in
a while shane black you know he grew up
at that
you know coming off overland in west la
and he kind of lived in that famous
house with writers and actors and
storytellers and these guys all kind of
helped each other out and built the
machine it's very rare
uh you know the the wilson brothers owen
and um
and the other one got him blinking luke
yeah i mean talented and they ran you
know did bottle rockets and all their
friends and
there's ways to do it napoleon dynamite
did it too but
by and large you think about how many
young filmmakers are out there and we
always go for hey mom do you want to
play the mom in my short
[Laughter]
you know when you were steven spielberg
and seven that worked
but when you're in film school you're
trying to make a career for yourself
you know again call the acting schools
you know there are a lot of acting
schools that have some
decent talented people that would sure
love to be a part of your film and they
will take it seriously and they will
learn to
learn the role and the craft is there
and the talent is there and
you know uncle vinnie playing dad is not
always the best idea
you know just
you know i mean now look i'll often use
an owner of a location if i know they're
a sag actor and they're good
like i have i have friends that own
locations that are actually working good
actors i'll say hey i'll trade you off i
want your location
but i'll give you i'll give you a few
lines in this movie like oh yeah sign me
up
but they're working actors also you know
so i think you always have to
try to put the right people in when you
can with the exception of with locals
in certain films especially if it's like
a certain region of the us
or or other part of the world there's
just people that
you just can't you can't get that from
central casting it's too good
you know and and you can you can
definitely tell
but it works in the film you know so
we're talking about getting
some uh some people that you just you
just find
just the gems oh it's you know
casting is it's interesting i say as
filmmakers you want to make friends with
a lot of different agencies
uh to this day i will i will reach out
to friends that own
boutique agencies you've never heard of
and say
i'm doing a film i need a cashier at a
country store
i need a hipster who can play guitar at
a campfire i need somebody who can
you know be a drug dealer on the corner
or i'll call a drug dealer in a corner
and say hey you want to play yourself in
a movie i'll give you 50 bucks you know
i mean sometimes you got to do that
um i find the people that are the best
together the people that do
what it is you want them to do if you're
not hiring an actor again it to me it's
always about getting the best person you
can in front of and behind the camera
so if you need something
and you're not getting it with what
you're auditioning go find somebody who
does it and tell them i just need you to
be yourself i want you to be a part of
this
i'm not going to embarrass you i just i
need and you'd be amazed i mean i
learned that from my dad you know we
worked with probated youth for a lot of
years
and we had a lot of of kids in our life
that we knew that had done a lot of
crooked stuff
and i remember one time we got a pilot
um
for uh i think it was time warner
television or warner cable
court tv something like that and they
wanted a bunch of reenactments of
burglaries and assaults and all that at
the end of the day we ended up i think
hiring
eight or nine of the kids that we worked
with that had done time in real prison
to play parts and they did better than
anybody they knocked it out of the park
because it's
who they were and look at homeboys
industry inc
is that father boyle yeah i mean you got
father boyle at homeboy industries i
mean we
i first learned about that when we were
shooting great iron gang half the extras
you walk around you go
you just know when you've worked around
real inmates
most your life like i have the swagger
the way they walk the way they talk the
way they move
and i remember saying at one point i
said where'd we get all these guys
because i know they've done time and
said oh
this great thing going on called homeboy
industries inc
you've got to check it out all these
kids have done time and i was like
that that makes sense that's so cool and
so i'm a big fan of that yeah sure
yeah there's nothing worse when someone
is supposed to play
someone in the underworld let's say and
they're so squeaky clean and it just
takes you
out and and there are there's there's
mannerisms there's just different signs
and
yeah watch a lot of music videos from
the 80s
because they would put a lot of the rock
stars girlfriends in when they were
supposed to be down without homeless
girls and you'd see these like
not tiny contain on the jaguar hood but
you know you would see
supermodels literally with like shoe
polish on their face digging through a
you know a bin looking for food and
you're like oh come on yeah
yeah when you work with dwayne johnson
and was it 2006 on the gridiron gang
did you have any idea he would be the
star that he is today
well i'm not surprised that he became
the star that he is today
um the guy is he he goes in 150
on everything he does he doesn't do
anything
half cocked um his commitment to
excellence i think it comes from his
upbringing
uh and also his you know he was an
accomplished
football player in college played with
the national champion
team with the miami hurricanes and then
obviously what he accomplished as a
wrestler and his humble beginnings and
if you know anything about him
you know huge disappointments going
through football the nfl and the cfl
and then having to start and beg vince
mcmahon for a job at you know these 150
a night barnyard wrestling tours that
they were doing
and you look at where he truly came from
and
and just his passion his devotion and
his his commitment to learning the craft
and making it as good as i think i think
there are those few people that you say
he can accomplish anything he wants
i i think that's somebody i'd put on top
of the list absolutely
do you remember anything notable from
being on set with dwayne johnson
yeah i mean sure i mean you know it was
a memorable time and fortunately i
you know proud to say that we remained
good friends
um you know here we are 14 years later
um
still can call him a friend still in
touch
he's you know as i said he his
commitment to excellence is second to
none
he takes so much pride and you ever talk
about somebody who
when they talk to anybody it didn't
matter if it was the guy who was
cleaning the toilets
it didn't matter if it was an extra it
didn't matter if it was the director or
me
producer or anybody when when he talked
to you he was there 100 percent
it was all about this moment with that
whoever he talked to
and i think the most memorable time for
me when we were making the film was we
were about
two or three weeks in we were shooting
uh during the
summer it was probably may or june
and we were shooting up at the prison in
malibu where we actually
my father and i shot the documentary we
went back and shot the scripted piece
with dwayne there
and he got really sick
he got a flu something when it was food
poisoning or what
it's something something happened and
you know it's one of those things you
know the medics were called you know
just it wasn't
he was it was just you know you're star
sick you get the medic there you have a
medic on set
and they were checking his his blood and
it's this and that and
and it was like first thing he was gonna
say is look you know we're here for
three months dude you want to call he
said no
no no no i got this he goes i just need
i need 10 minutes let me just give me 10
minutes
let me hydrate let me let some of the
aspirin kick in let me
we'll do this and what was interesting
it was his first
real deep scene with one of the kids
where he was interacting with one of the
kids from the program
and i don't know if anybody remembers
the film it's a scene where he's
encounters the the samoan running back
junior
in the middle of the yard at night the
kid had a call because it was his
daughter's birthday and he was pissed
that he was missing his birthday
and dwayne wouldn't let him be part of
the football program because he had a
hair trigger all he did was fight
and spend all his time in solitary so
dwayne sit down you're not going to be
any part of the team so
what this scene was was the two of them
coming together
and this kid convincing dwayne that he
can be a part of the program and be a
productive part of it
and i knew at that moment
you know we've all seen people tough it
out but you want to talk about being
able to completely
block out what he was dealing with and
rise to the occasion or accept the
challenge which was the saying on
gridiron gang
he did it and i knew at that moment i
said god this guy
you know he he wasn't created we'll just
say that you know there's enough
created fabricated tough guys in
hollywood
or greats in hollywood and and i knew at
that moment this guy was genuine he was
sincere
he was passionate and you know went all
in
take us back to the documentary that you
did
how did that come about funny story
um we my father my stepmother and i had
done
a host of reality shows before the term
was
a term there were documentaries uh on
probated youth it started with desperate
passage back in 1986
then became made in voyage desperate
passage was with michael landon made in
voyage with sharon glass then it was a
step apart with marlo thomas and then
you know eddie james almost had done a
few of them and they were just they had
got you know these wonderful great
actors to host
or narrate these documentaries about
probated youth that we did
and it was basically they were done to
show america the hearts cry of
troubled youth that they are still kids
that they weren't raised they were
basically
put out and often were raised by street
gangs or
you know by pimps and drug dealers and
that these these were still children
they were still human beings that
deserved a chance
and um like you know we learned over the
years that a kid didn't
care what you thought unless you unless
you knew you cared
and then once we broke through that some
remarkable things happened and we ended
up doing things about eight or nine
so we had done a slew of these and had a
lot of success and
a couple of studios that optioned a few
of them to be turned into scripted films
and my stepmom linda who i call mom but
my mom was reading the la times and
there was a story in the metro section
about
one of the jails that we had done a lot
of filming at was starting
a football team within the confines of
the jail and the hope was
that these kids would be allowed to go
out and play against the straight
schools
and they started with an eight-man
football team or seven-man team the
first year and then
the second year when we heard about it
and it finally made press
was they were they were gonna fill a
full team
so mom came into the office and was all
excited threw the thing down on my dad's
desk and said oh my god this is this is
a movie
my dad was like yeah yeah we
we've done these and linda god bless her
mom she was like no no no no no
this is the one this is the one so she
pushed him pretty hard
so after a few days he called probation
and said hey it's lee how you doing we
want to come up we'd love to do a
documentary we saw the article in the la
times and we've been doing this with
probation at this point for
seven years we've had all the success
and done well
and they kind of laughed us off and said
yeah get in line
like what are you talking about well
ever since that article came out every
studio in hollywood wants to do it we're
engaging you name the actor you name the
producer they're trying to negotiate the
rights this is
this is out of your wheelhouse guys you
know
so we kind of we're like well that's too
bad that we we got excited about it
assuming it was going to be ours and we
lost it
so about three weeks went by
and the head of probation called my
father and said are you still interested
in doing the uh
the the story on the prison football
team and my father said well
why i thought you had hollywood's elite
yeah we we do and we have and we got a
quick
quick crash course on how hollywood does
things and we
all decided we kind of like the way you
guys do things so if you'd like to do it
the rights are yours we'll see here they
start practice in three days
and we didn't have any money and
we we ended up just beg borrowing and
stealing some cameras and
got the funding after the fact we'd like
raced up to get it because i mean how do
you call somebody say we need funding in
three days we just we kind of
knew what we could go to some of our
trusted investors from the past shows
but we just rolled the dice and grabbed
a couple cameras and sound and a small
crew of four of us is what it usually
was
and went up and shot and we made the
documentary
we got the funding and when i say the
funding i think it was probably 200 000
dollars to
to make this documentary and what was
really funny
is in making it um you know
we covered the first game and what you
saw in the
the film with the rock was a direct lift
i mean basically
jeff mcguire our writer watched the
documentary and just wrote
what was there it's all there and it was
interesting because the kids had lost
their first game cried like babies
we all went our separate ways that was a
movie it was over as far as we were
concerned it was over and
my father was speaking uh for janet reno
who was the attorney general at the time
in atlanta for a big fbi conference they
wanted my dad there because he
understood so much about the
youth of today and incarcerated youth
and they just kind of wanted to
understand from somebody who'd worked 20
years with these kids
kind of to hear his take on it not being
a clinical psych or a cop you know let's
let's hear somebody who's worked with
these kids different point of view
so my dad goes to atlanta with my mom
and they're gone and
it was like they've made a week out of
it because my uncle lived in florida and
they were going to spend time with them
i get this phone call from my father he
said hey uh what are you doing this
weekend and i was like
i'm just hanging out what's up he said
you know the documentary we did on the
film
with the football team i said of course
he said well those
little brats are playing for the state
championship i need you to get a couple
cameras i need you to go handle it and
then there's an awards banquet after
that i need you to go deal with it i'm
stuck in atlanta so i had to scramble
and
get a couple of great cameramen i think
it was phillip hearn and steve elkins
and chip brooks did sound and me
directing and we went out and shot
their championship game against
montclair prep where they lost 13 to 7
and and then the awards banquet at the
old sportsman's lodge right after that
and then that was it and that's how it
came about
and nobody wanted it it was interesting
with all the success we had
nobody wanted it it sat um was
steve bell who had basically given us
anything we wanted at ktla and tribune
to launch our shows was no longer there
he had gone to start i think stars or
encore so
we were dealing with a new regime at
ktla and
tribune and they didn't really capture
the vision
and our agents at caa at the time
watched it and said that's a that's a
cute little
documentary and you know
my dad went back to get the vhs from the
projectionist at caa and he was wiping
his eyes he said i heard what he said
don't listen to a word
this is one of the most powerful things
i've ever seen you're going to do great
with this
and we finally got it on tv it won an
emmy for uh
i don't know what the heck it won for
but it was it was a big national emmy it
won my dad
and uh the day after it aired on tv
every studio but paramount called
to make a bid every a-list actor you can
imagine was calling i mean we went into
the office the next day there was you
know the thing ran out of tape
and the next week the phone just rang
off the hook you know it was everybody
trying to get the rights
so it was an incredible experience it
was a whirlwind
and then it took another 14 years to get
made
so can we can we have a condensed
version of those 14 years and why
do you think that's really nothing
okay why do you think that is well it
was easy i mean you know mark canton ran
the studio
uh if they had to have it because
everybody else wanted it they paid the
most and gave us the prettiest pitch
so jeff mcguire had just written the uh
in the line of fire with clint eastwood
and wolfgang
pedersen and got the academy award
nomination so he was our writer so
the film acquired two million and a half
i think two and a half million dollars
of
studio costs against it and then canton
was out he was fired
and the new regime came in and usually
what happens is all those films that
have been sitting around going to turn
around so they put gridiron in a
turnaround they were like yeah you know
whatever
this is the old so after uh 18 months of
development another reason i don't like
it the film sat with a two and a half
million dollar lien against it
and i don't think a month went by in 12
years
where somebody didn't call and say
what's going on with gridiron we'd love
to make it and we said hey there's a two
and a half million dollar fee against it
if you want to pay off sony
we can start from scratch and make the
movie and most people
would hang up before we were done with
the sentence it was like yeah not gonna
happen
and uh um yeah so
14 years went by it was from 1993 till
2005.
so what is that 12 years went by and
then
neil moritz who we had known years ago
when he first started his career with
juice and
stoned age we always had a respect for
each other and neil had become
obviously quite the producer with things
like fast and furious and a whole list
of other films
and just called it neil one day when i
heard
friday night lights was getting done and
they were gonna make invincible they
were gonna make
we are marshall they were making facing
the giants
we talked earlier about how hollywood
likes to keep doing the same thing
called neil and said do you want to make
red iron gang he said yes
let's do it and we had a meeting my
father and i went and saw neil
and he said do me a favor before you
come to my office shane
give me a list of cast he said this
thing has fallen on its face time and
time again it's about the cast we got to
make this thing cast right so
i spent the night putting together a
cast that i thought was going to change
the world and put the world
on its ear and while doing that my wife
girlfriend at the time val
said come in here i want you to see what
i'm watching on tv and i ignored her i
said i'm busy i'm
playing hollywood producer she came into
my office and she had tears pouring down
her face and said you need to you need
to come in here she said i got your guy
and i said come on man
really she said come in well she was
watching the a e
biography on the rock and you know he
had been arrested i think a dozen times
before his 18th birthday
football saved him and how he thought he
was going to be an nfl
player coming off a championship college
team and ended up breaking his neck or
rupturing all his discs
started over from nothing and i
watched and was just fascinated
and i literally hit the delete button on
the document on my on my computer
went in to see neil the next day we
caught up hadn't seen each other in
person in a while congratulated him on
all of his success
and he said great all right where's your
list and i said
i didn't make a list and you can see he
deflated and i said i got the i got the
guy
he said kind of needed a list what do
you got and i said
the rock and he thought for a minute and
he yelled to his assistant
and said when's my meeting with the rock
and she said you're having dinner with
him tomorrow
he looked at me and he said i'm having
dinner with him tomorrow we're trying to
figure out something to do this could be
the one
he said get me a copy of the the
documentary you guys did on dvd
and let's find that original script that
mcguire wrote
15 years ago he was probably going to
need to be dusted off and modernized but
i want to go with that script just give
me the dvd and have it back here by
tomorrow i'm having dinner with them
tomorrow night
so i didn't have a dvd of gridiron gang
it was on vhs
so i found a place that converted it for
me in literally a half a day
sunset video ran it down to neal's
office just in time
and two days later neil called and said
duane wants to meet you guys and we
hung out at the jail and it was a great
experience and he he encountered the
kids and saw what we were doing and said
i commit let's make the movie and
14 years later we were rolling camera
and that was it
so that that meeting took place and then
he committed to it so take me on
why people were passing on it i'm
confused sorry
why were people passing on it within
that time when he hadn't reached the
level that he
is now at i'm confused nobody passed on
it once
once he signed on and went right to sony
we had a green light picture he was
very much in demand it was the
documentary that we struggled to get
seen
uh i see like doing the documentary and
having tremendous success i mean we had
already won 12 emmys and had 32
nominations
and nobody wanted to watch this one
which was kind of part of the same genre
sure as yeah and then finally we kind of
bartered a deal at ktla to get them to
put it on
and once it got on every studio wanted
it so we spent eight months
getting quartered by everybody from
disney to sony to warner
to universal and then went with sony
and then canton developed it and then he
got fired so then everything just wanted
to turn around so it's that
we just we couldn't do anything with it
because there was a 2 million lien
against it from sony
and what was really cool maybe this will
help clarify neil because of his
reputation
and his deals that he had at sony he was
like look the two and a half million
dollars they're claiming needs to be
paid back he goes that was 14 years ago
that money's been written off it's done
it's gone it's a new regime
i will deal with that and neil went in
and talked to amy pascal who
who captured the vision of the project
he was very excited about
it and said all right let's wave the two
and a half let's let's put a new let's
put this back on a fast track and
you know get a start we want we're
excited about let's do it
fortunately they were excited about
dwayne and we were rolling
he had to go shoot a film i think it was
doom
or the game plan and then i think it was
doom and then as soon as he got back we
started ours immediately
and then off we went and then what was
the reception once the
the narrative version was finished once
the film came out it did very well it
was frustrating because we finished it
in uh i think it was oh i want to say oh
five or
six and in september we were supposed to
come out
during the super bowl like build up to
the super bowl we wanted to give him
that football movie
and at the last minute sony decided yeah
we're going to push it another nine
months we'll come out in september
so it's like oh it's only been 13 years
what's another nine months
film came out it went number one did
very well it was number one for two
weeks um
it did well i think the fact that there
were three other football movies out
like invincible and we are marshall and
facing the giants didn't help us but
it's still i think it did 30 or 38
million domestic in the box office
one thing that you don't hear about was
we were very fortunate with home video
sony created blu-ray as we all know and
there was a race between two mediums it
was blu-ray and another
home high-def system i don't remember
what it was
and sony decided when they launched
blu-ray they were going to do it on two
films they did spider-man 2
and they did gridiron so what happened
is this gridiron came back and dwayne
had become such a big star during that
time
the dvd and what little vhs sales were
were very very strong and then when they
recycled it for blu-ray why it was still
relevant
it more than doubled again so it had
this extra
boost that nobody expected which was
really special
so yeah that was that was gridiron it
did well it was fun
and you know it's nice to to have that
that in my resume and i don't mean that
it's it's you know
a career that's now 48 years going it's
nice to have had the number one
blockbuster
and it gives me we talked about chasing
that success i had as a 16 year old it
gave me that validation it
hit 30 37 36
and it it it really reminds me
everything's okay you know maybe every
10 15 years i'll have one
but maybe i won't again but it's okay i
i slayed the dragon and i can just move
forward and be comfortable with what i
do
and you had some people give you advice
as well that had also had success
early in life who who kind of like put
things in perspective
i know i was very very fortunate you
know with some of the the people that i
run with or worked with or befriended
over the years you know people that come
to mind or people like charlie sheen or
brett michaels
uh you know there's the singer from
poison obviously rock of love celebrity
apprentice everybody knows brat now
uh from all different different places
and brett and i have been
best friends since probably 93 or 94.
and here's a guy who had tremendous
success came from very humble beginnings
you know him and
other guys from poison jumped in evandro
from harrisburg pennsylvania to l.a
lived in an abandoned warehouse
or an abandoned laundromat for three
years trying to make it and they had
in the 80s and 90s had so much success
and then the music styles changed and
talk about a guy who was able to
reinvent himself
you know brett's had to reinvent himself
three times and he's done well every
time
and the one thing he taught me was
the cool thing is you know when he had
every rose has its thorn was his number
one hit
so we we kind of joked about i had my
gridiron he had his every rose it was
kind of funny when that finally happened
and he said here's the cool thing about
that nobody can ever take it away from
you
he goes there will be another 52 movies
this year that'll go number one
he goes that's fine but you still went
number one
and i never forgot that i never wore
that
conceitedly or with arrogance but it was
it gave me
the affirmation that i think so many
artists you know you want that and that
that helped um but he always gave me the
greatest advice he always said
no one to get off the merry-go-round you
know we talked about that you know
getting off the merry-go-round at the
right time there's people that jump off
it too soon and it's still moving too
fast
and that's not good you know you think
about getting off a merry-go-round too
fast it'll kill you
and then there's the people that hang on
it too long and it comes to a stop
and people are waiting for you to get
off he said what you have to do is
figure out
how to ride certain moments of your
career and know
when to step away and it's never easy
you know when i say that i talk about a
film that you have a film that does well
you can you can i'll use a very generic
term you can milk that
as long as you think you can but you try
not to over milk it
you try not to hinge your your future on
it you realize hey we were fortunate we
were blessed
we had a moment in time that nobody can
take from us
and there are going to be 51 other
number one movies this year so we need
to get moving
and let the next people come in and do
what they need to do and enjoy the
moment and let's go on and go back to
work
so i've had some good advice with some
people in my life that have kind of been
that done there
i think that you know been very helpful
to me why not give up on the project
earlier
10 years in you're talking about giving
it up why it was sitting at sony
well we did because it was in turn
around and i didn't have two and a half
million dollars laying around with
accruing interest to
pay them off to get it back the one
thing that always gave us hope
was as i said i don't think a month went
by in 12 years where somebody
called and said hey what's going on
there was actually a time where peter
gruber called and said um
i know you've got your your deal with
sony that's got to be paid off i used to
be head of sony
i may be able to make that work i really
would like to try to make this into
something so we we did a deal with
with mandalay peter guber before we
ended up making it with neil
um there were a few people that that
would try to do some creative
so when you have a project and it's it's
generating that interest for so long
with people with that kind of juice
you never want to throw that away you
know we talked earlier about what's a
good script what's a good story what can
you use to get a foothold in this
industry
well when you have a product and you've
got the peter goobers or the neil
moritzes
or the joe roths or the bobby neumeyers
calling you on a regular basis saying
what's going on man let's you know
well okay there's something there you
don't just bury it
you can't you can't so i think there was
always the hope that it would get done
one day i think my dad and i had always
kind of said you know one day maybe
something will come along maybe we'll
have success somewhere else enough where
we can buy out that two million and get
it done
you know um but it all worked out
and so when you filmed at the
sportsman's lodge both schools were
there right for this dinner
no this was all for the kids oh okay
it's all for the mustangs interesting
yeah and i don't think it was a
sportsman's lodge it was
it was a shh it was it's where
it's where um there's a sushi spot there
right now it's an all you can eat sushi
place off wineca
and tampa across from the ash it used to
be called the smorgasbord inn
it was a sports banquet lodge similar to
sportsman's lodge but it wasn't so
you have to put that in but it's so
funny i just say sportsman's lodge
because everybody knows it but it was
like the swedish inn or something like
that
okay yeah it was it was the parents and
the kids and sadly there was only a few
parents
you know we had 48 kids on the team and
i think eight parents showed up
it was tragic i'm sad that's just that's
the way it is
how much should a filmmaker pay
themselves whatever they can
i mean you know at the end of the day it
depends you know when i say filmmaker i
think about me
i'm involved concept to delivery you
know i just got into it with somebody
the other day who worked on our last
film and they worked i think
four to six weeks on breakeven i just
celebrated my 27th month on the film
last week
now we lost five months of covid but
during the covet time we had to
repurpose our distribution outlets
what we were going to do so i ended up
dealing with a whole new list of
deliverables
a whole new group of people with
different qc demands you know for
quality control for release
so you know there are people on that
film that worked
three or four weeks i got paid a hell of
a lot more than i did and
you know here i am i'm literally like
almost two and a half years in
and i wouldn't change a thing about it i
don't do it for the money i do it
because i love
to do it i i just i enjoy the process
but you know i always say be
fair you're going to have an investor
that you want to be able to have an open
books relationship with if you have an
investor that says i'd like to see the
books
you don't want to that's not a good
position to be in there are plenty of
people you can google in hollywood who
have
gone to prison i always say just
when you hand an investor a budget you
live by it and you can put clauses in
your financing agreement that say hey if
we come in
under budget i get to keep it or if i
come in under budget let's split what's
left or
you know but i i think whatever you can
pay yourself if you're raising the money
you're creating the content you're
creating jobs for
you know and break even 125 people
you know get what you can you know
because you're going to give the money
back to your investors i trust
so you may never see another dime you
know
so i i never try to tell people what
they should or shouldn't pay themselves
i just say
if you were the investor of the film and
you your filmmaker was being paid what
you're paying yourself would you feel
comfortable looking would you would you
would you be okay looking at those books
and i think if you can answer yes that's
fine i've never had an
investor i've never had an investor ask
me in 30 years of raising independent
money how much i'm paying myself i've
had their lawyer ask me once
one time i had a lawyer ask me and i've
never been asked since
and i was very direct with the lawyer at
the time i belonged to four unions
and i said well i'm a union member
for the following guilds i will be doing
all four of these jobs on the film
i am not going to be taking my union
rates i have parked my union membership
so i could do this project
this is what i normally get paid here's
what i'm doing it for
and he was like wow okay i just he was
like i just didn't know
i thought he was questioning my value he
just was curious
but um i i say you know you're gonna be
you know every film is a love affair
you're gonna walk away from it scarred
heartbroken chipped teeth black guys
gray
bald fat thin it's it's gonna it's gonna
do this to you you know you're gonna
lose 20 pounds in pre-production you're
going to put on a few pounds during
production and you're going to put on 25
pounds of post
you know so i i just say you know be
fair to yourself
um realize that this is going to be
probably a year to an 18-month process
and what is your time worth and uh don't
bankrupt the project
because you have to be greedy or get
paid you don't budget yourself
accordingly you're a line item
you know every job you do is a line item
if you if you're
writing a script you're you should be
paid as a writer if you're producing you
should be paid as a producer if you're
directing it the same and editing it the
same
if you're supervising music and doing
post-production and deliverables that
cost
somebody's gotta get paid to do it right
so which production taught you the most
you don't have to name names or the name
of the movie or who you work with
but it just taught you the most whether
it was something about yourself
whether it was something about how you
were working with people
something where it changed you in a lot
of ways
could be for better or worse
i you know i grew up as you know
doing independent shoestring
thread budgets with my dad i mean we
were doing
we were doing films that had million
dollar budgets for 20 grand
back in the day when we were shooting in
film and
i learned so you have to learn so much
if you're gonna make it work i mean we
literally did these films on crews of
three to five
so you could be shooting a camera
and you could be also holding a boom
pole and mixing an
fp32 mixer on your hip as you're trying
to pull focus and shoot and
you kind of become those you know those
musicians that were the the symbols on
your knees and the bass drum and the
tambourine on their head and
you kind of do a lot of that i think i
got shape doing those
the first major film i produced was a 12
million
film for miramax back in the day and
it was frustrating because i knew how to
do so much and wasn't allowed
but what was really cool when we got
there i still got to do so much i
had co-written the script and i'd
produced the film one of the producers
of the film
and before we were done i ended up
doubling for one of the big stars
i ended up cutting the film and ended up
being
you know working with the post
supervisors and the music supervisors
and
i got to do a lot of things again and
that was really fun and i
it reminded me that
you know when you work in big
budgetville it's funny there's people to
do everything
you know it's spread out so much
but i come from a a place where
everybody did it so much and i i like
when everybody does so much
and what's funny is after living in
covid going back to work where the
demands or the crews are smaller
the people who know how to do much are
the ones who are going to be called
because i know when we're crewing up for
this new film that we're gearing up to
do
everybody's got to be able to do a lot
of things i mean even my camera
operators
they got to be able to do a lot of
things you know my my it's no longer
hair makeup and wardrobe and props it's
one person who's going to handle all
four of those it's the only way it's
gonna work
you know and uh so i learned from
everything
every production i've ever done karen i
learned from
and i i appreciate each experience
i learned something new on every show
what's the worst piece of advice you've
received and it actually turned out to
be true
but at the time when you heard it you
thought i'm not listening to this person
worst piece of advice i ever got that
turned out to be true
i think the worst advice i ever got
that turned out to be true was um was
something that my photo teacher taught
me in my senior year in high school mr
ken neely
he uh he called me in after class one
day and he said i'm worried about your
future
he said you're a jack of all trade
master of none
and i said what do you mean he said well
you're here in photo class you're doing
okay you take a decent picture because
you race dirt bikes
you play drums in a band and you've won
an emmy already
you know what's your plan dude like
you gotta like and
i got really concerned about that and i
gave up a lot of things in my life
because of that
and what's weird is i don't know if that
was bad advice but it was true
and i didn't listen to the advice
and i just became this guy that did a
lot of things
that i i do well enough to to work
and to stay relevant am i a great
storyteller
no am i a great director that's putting
the world on their on their ear
no not reinventing the wheel am i a
great editor that's gonna
you know come up with a way to cut a
film differently than anybody else has
no so i'm not able to put all of my
energy into one thing
i am really glad now that i'm almost 50
i've been able to stay working for as
long as i have because
i did become a jack of all trade
i don't think if i if if i had listened
to his advice
and not pumped the brakes after a year
and a half of getting rid of everything
in my life that was
important to me i would have truly
learned the craft
of everything i could so i know that's
not
the answer to the question you asked but
that is the one thing that has
constantly haunted me over the years was
the advice
did i do it right what did i give up and
then how did i reboot myself and then i
looked later and i go well i
i've actually been i'm okay
so you know did you tell other people
about that conversation and
did they steer you away from doing too
much
it's funny every time i start a film
everybody tells me you do too much we're
going to be here to support you
you do too much we're going to take a
lot of it off you
and i don't know if it's me
not truly embracing and trusting the
people i work with enough to
to trust that that's gonna happen or
it's going to be okay
um i'm not a control freak
i'm very hands-on but i've also been
around too many productions when people
assume somebody's going to take care of
something and
it's just it's unacceptable when they
fall through the cracks and i'm just
somebody that knows if i handle it it
won't
doesn't mean i'm perfect it doesn't mean
i'm great it just means that i know if
it's on my list to do's it's
i i know if it's on my list of to do's
it's going to get done
and i'm very hard to trust people with
doing those things so
um again i don't know if i'm answering
your question
properly but you know i
i have spent my entire career being told
by people well we just want you to
direct and we just want you to deal with
this and
i haven't been able to do that because
you know i haven't felt
that i haven't had the peace in my heart
to do that and i wish i had and it's
nothing anybody has done
it's it's my own problem it's not
somebody has dropped the ball or let me
down it's that fear
it's waking up at two in the morning as
i talk about in the book in a sweat
scared to death the wrong actor is going
to show up tomorrow scared to death
we didn't get a permit scared to death
that we didn't order the drone or
whatever
and i know if i'm handling it it's not
going to fall through the cracks
it sounds like too you love to be busy i
do ambidextrous you're always doing
things adhd but same difference right or
gemini
yeah so so you just certain people just
love to be
they they just have certain ways about
them they love to be busy i love to be
busy i'd love not to be as busy as i am
but i always find that i'm never not i'm
never still
i'm never still and i always say i'm
going to stop taking things on and then
three days go by and i'm sitting here
looking at four other projects that i
just committed to get involved with
what was i thinking but somehow some way
they get done
yeah you know yeah i mean i think just
certain people are hardwired differently
i am definitely hardwired differently
but no i mean not in a bad way but
yeah but just wanting to to say or they
they like they have a tv show on
they're cleaning something over here
they're looking at twitter there's just
yeah just some people i don't vacation
well i don't i don't take days off i
don't vacation luckily my wife is kind
of
we love our little world and what we do
and there's not we're not
people that take two weeks every year to
go do anything you know we take day
trips
once every week or every other week go
do fun things we we're always together i
mean we both work from home so
we're together all the time so we have
our time together but
i never oh my god i gotta get away and
go to hawaii or i need to
jump on a plane and go somewhere you
know i it's never been in my dna
no cruises no god no what are the top
five reasons an investor
will invest in your project top five
reasons an investor
will invest in somebody or their project
i think number one is because
they want to help you i think anytime
you go to an investor it's somebody
who's probably in
better circumstance than you are or at
least has the ability to
help get you to the next level make your
dreams come true
i have had investors that get behind me
simply because
there's a trust level there's a feeling
of
wanting to help me get to another level
of my career
sometimes it's because they feel the
project's important
often it's because they want
to get a tax write-off i mean there's
the business side of the business too
you know i i
believe that you know astute investors
are taught by business managers to avoid
three or four different investments one
one is nightclubs and restaurants
one is recording studios and the other
is movies i mean that's just like those
are the three you don't do
so getting private equity together for
making motion pictures is
is difficult we have kind of a stigma
going in there's already a couple of
strikes against us
so what's important is that we're able
to appeal to an
independent and i'm sorry what's
important is that we're able to
[Music]
appeal to individual financiers or
investors with what it is that we're
trying to achieve with our work i think
that's really important and i
as i talk about a lot in my book i think
it's really important for
for filmmakers to really do their
research on people don't just go meet
rich people
meet people who can identify with what
it is you're trying to do
you may have a passion project that you
want to do but
you can do your research on a specific
investor and learn that they may have a
passion or an interest
think about doing something that is
something that they will be more open or
interested in doing
and go down that road so when you meet
with them they're excited and thrilled
about what it is you're trying to pitch
take care of business do that and then
they're going to come usually if it's
successful in a good
a good journey and say what is it you
want to do and that's often been the
hardest thing because you know again as
filmmakers we're myopic we think about
what we want to do
and often you have to think about what
other people want to do that are in a
position of helping us so
i always say go in with an open heart
going with an open mind be willing to
bob and weave a little bit off of your
plan
at the end of the day the goal is to
work the goal is to make new
relationships i mean i have investors
that we've known for 35 years that have
faithfully gotten involved i have
investors that have invested
one time that i've known 25 years and
we're still best of friends and they did
it one time and
didn't ruin the friendship it just they
wanted to try and i have
i have you know friends that i've i've
known for
25 and 30 years who would never invest
in this business and they are more than
capable
it's just to each his own but i think
people will want to i say you know you
always have to remember you're under the
watchful eye if you are going to
approach people
to invest in you realize
you're going to become an open book
they're going to look at your social
media they're going to look at how you
conduct yourself they're going to invite
you to parties where there's going to be
alcohol because they want you to drink
and they want to see how you're going to
behave
people don't realize that i mean i know
a lot of
real close calls friends of mine have
had over the years we're like god you
know i had an investor on the hook
had this party i drank too much passed
out at the guys play well
duh you know they're they're almost
saying
here let me see how you do what can i
trust you with and just remember
you have to treat their money like it's
your money and i think
you know some of the success that we've
had with our investors it's not always
about how much the return on investment
was it's about
a trust level it's about the experience
let them feel involved you know i send
my investors
emails at the end of every night telling
them good bad or indifferent how the day
went
and then once we're in post production i
fill them in once a week
and it's that way in pre-production too
i just feel that they they're we're
doing what we do because they trust in
us and they give us the means to do it
you have to let them feel involved
and a lot of times these investors
believe it or not are a little bored
doing what they do and they see this as
kind of a neat little fun outlet
so involve them you know let them feel a
part of what you're doing
that being said have you ever put money
from a credit card
into any of your projects have i ever
put
money from a credit card into one of my
projects
um oh yeah um there's been times where
i've done
uh self-funded projects you know i talk
about the 500 pilot i talk about the 10
movie i mean i had an investor that came
to me with 20 dollars
and said i wanna make a movie with you
and
um didn't account for
sag bonds and the fact that it was kind
of a sequel remake to something we did
that was on sag experimental and had to
repay all the actors for the work they
did the year before
so that 20 000 turned into 12 000 really
quick
and the investor was cool enough to say
i'll throw an additional amount in for
the bond but that's it because he would
get his bond back so we really had about
12 grand to work with
and there was a couple of days that it
was kind of like all right you know
let's feed the crew well tonight and
just you know it's part of it
um but i've never had to like
max out a credit card to make a movie or
anything i i
haven't had to do that i maxed out
credit cards doing other stupid
i know no swearing i had to throw no
more jet skis though no more jet skis no
that's over that's
that's over good question though yeah no
i mean it's about we did dark side
i put about 3 500 on credit cards to
feed i just the people weren't eating
well enough and the budget was so cheap
and they were all working for nothing
and it was like goddamn i gotta i gotta
feed these guys
so i just i told my wife i'm like i i
can't
do the subway and pizza thing for 15
days we're gonna feed them every three
days
really well but we did we did and i
think we got i think we got a good
result from that you know and you feed
them well happy crew
happy moving right just want to be fed
and respected
you know if you invest 250 000 in a
movie does that mean it's going to sell
for at least 250 000
oh hell no it's like putting 75 million
into a movie and sometimes it makes back
10 million i mean there's no guarantees
um obviously the more money you have to
play with
um hopefully the better the cast the
more bankable the cast the more
well-known the cast but you don't always
have that i mean we've done a lot of 250
movies and i think again it comes
down to telling a good story it comes
down to getting a good cast that's
recognizable and marketable
and it's also about those locations you
know
take people places they want to go make
them never feel like they're watching a
000 movie you know i take a lot of pride
in in my 20 000
movie we really did for 12 grand a lot
of people don't know the story of that
and what it did for my career i actually
got more out of my career because of
that
than i did from gridiron gang um and i
did it after gridiron gang
what's interesting is i had done a film
i wanted to tell a story
and i um for me it was about showing
people what i could do on a dime that's
as you know if you've read my book it's
about making films for a dime that turn
and make a dollar that's what it's about
so for me i went out and we made this
let's just say twelve thousand dollar
movie after i put in a few grand on my
credit card to feed
um i had a friend who was very tight
with sumner redstone who at the time who
you know he just passed but sometimes
they had a viacom
and friend of mine got it to sumner and
said friend of mine made this
i don't know if you want to watch it or
not i want you to watch it and check it
out
he's like why am i watching it well
there's pretty girls in it you'll like
it
but i want you to watch it for the
production value when you're done
watching i want you to guess what you
made it for
so sumner sat through this 90 minute
debuckery of mine
it wasn't a great story it just was a
pretty movie and he
was pleased and impressed with it and
glad he watched it and he said oh i
guess he probably put a couple million
into it
and my friend said well he actually put
about 12 grand into it
sumner picked up the phone called brad
gray god rest him he's dead too
picked up the phone and called brad gray
and said i just saw a movie that
apparently was made for twelve thousand
five hundred dollars
i could have sworn it was made for a
couple million i need to get it to you
film got sent to brad i got a call from
brad gray the next day
he said yeah i need you to start meeting
with our people we want to get you in
here i
met with les moonves i met with michael
balbre who was running paramount at the
time
and it opened up amy powell who was
running in surge which is you know did
paranormal activity and a lot of other
great films and
that film opened up a lot of doors for
me because it showed people what i could
do for a dime
and it and it allowed my investors to
come back out of the woodwork who i
hadn't worked with in many years because
you know you go make a film with
sony you're not hitting people up for a
quarter million dollars to make movies
you're making a you know you're making a
studio movie
so it reopened those great opportunities
and kind of
just reminded me okay you don't need big
budgets to make
something look nice now we just got to
focus on making better movies
and it's been a fun journey but yeah we
um
david bulberry was the guy at paramount
but um
it it opened those doors for me that you
know having a number one blockbuster
never got me so i really encourage
people to make those low-budget
glossy good-looking films if your story
sucks
they better look good and i went in on
the merit of guess what i did it for
and people thought you know six hundred
thousand most people who were in the
know figured 600
to a million it was a twenty thousand
fifteen thousand dollar movie
yeah that actually ended up being twelve
because didn't you
you lost some of the money what was it
20 credits 20 or 25 000
was the original agreement but because
of our
previous jaw with sag and those actors
we had to repay them for their first
so we lost about eight grand of sag so
that came down to about 12
and then you know we ended up
you know probably putting in about 2 800
of my own for food
and stuff so yeah you know about 15 000
wow
how long was the shoot how many times 12
days 12 days
shoot pick did it i did a day of uh i
did a day
of second unit with two of the actors
because they were friends of mine they
did it off the grid you know i wanted
them in the car driving
you know drive-bys and stuff and then i
went out and just grabbed a camera and
just second united the hell out of it
you know got those great magic hour
shots and just filled up the
just filled it up with some pretty you
know but it was well shot it was well
acted um you know we had sean young
betsy russell from saw ron masak who's
been in everything
courtney gaines from children of the
corn i mean every face in it was
recognizable jason pace ryan
um oh i'm blanking on ryan's name it's
my fault there was just some really good
talent in that film
and uh i was proud of it because it
looked pretty it was a beautiful movie
it was a horrible movie but it was a
beautiful movie why was it horrible
it was just stupid it was you know i did
i i
did the first one which was a pure story
about a story i wanted to tell and that
was the pilot that i did for 500 bucks
and somebody saw it and said oh my god
you got to make a sequel to this and
that was that was the mistake
story-wise there was no sequel but
somebody was throwing 20 bucks you know
20 grand down to make a movie
i'm not doing anything this week let's
do it you know and so we did it
do you think that if you'd had more time
you guys said it was a 12-day shoot if
you'd had more time would it have been
better or
no the story was fundamental it was a
horrible script
no it looked good i mean you know again
as a 15 12 to 15 000
movie that some people thought we spent
six hundred thousand to two million to
make
so it visually was fine it was
it was just the script was written in
like a week and it was just in no
development notes it was like oh here
was the prequel just just let's just
carry on and write and tell a story and
it was it was just
you know it's more of an experiment i
see yeah it was fun
what's the shortest amount of time
you've written a script i did
a 36 hour fade in to the end
for emmett and furla films um
project called bad news that i wrote for
them
and i did it and i did it on a tuesday
wednesday
thursday without sleep no drugs
without sleep and i crashed
thursday at some point i
physically collapsed in my condo and i
woke up at some point friday
printed it out called them and furlough
drove it to them
at the warner lot and they optioned it
they called me monday said we love it
it's exactly what we need we want it
that was that was three days nonstop
the lack of sleep help you get into a
mindset was it some type of a sci-fi
fantasy no no it was an action film it
was i knew the story i wanted to tell
and emmitt and furlough were friends we
had done a film or two with them
and they were buying they were working
with people at the time that i worked
with in the past they were working with
avi lerner
and cassie elways and mark rifkin and
some of those guys from the late 90s
that i had worked with that were just
cranking out these
10 to 20 million dollar action movie so
i knew what they wanted
and they were they were optioning
scripts and they were paying to do it
and these guys
i pitched george on it over the phone
and he said oh yeah that sounds cool
give me a script and this was like on
tuesday i hung up the phone it was like
three o'clock in the afternoon i just
started writing
i started writing and i i collapsed at
some point thursday
and realized that i wrote the end
and uh did you wake up and like the room
was spinning or what happened when did
someone find you
i was living alone at the time it was
after my first
uh my first divorce i was back living
alone
uh you know us bachelors when we find
our way back to bachelorhood usually
live
it was crazy it was just i remember that
time very vividly
and i remember writing it tuesday
afternoon
collapsing at some point thursday and
you know every when you wake up friday
everything's still a blur and i just
remember hitting print there was 96
pages and i just hit print
i punched hold them put a brad in them
called their office and make sure dow
was there a guy at the time who was head
of of development and i said dallas
shane i'm coming will you give me a pass
he goes yeah
yeah we're waiting for you dude drove
onto the warner lot gave it to dow and
said enjoy and
george called me i think monday or two
and said yeah dude you got a deal this
is great
i i will say george has better taste
than that this was 25 years ago
but yeah that was the fastest script i
ever wrote
wow yeah a lot of coffee
oh yeah crown and coffee i don't know
why
crown oil and coffee oh wow i don't know
how an empty stomach
oh wow yeah you gotta stay awake wow and
the little purple bag yeah
probably smoked a lot too so i went
through a phase with smoking a lot i
think i
probably went through about 19 packs of
cigarettes that week
[Laughter]
good times they got them vegan now i'm
making up you know trying to take care
of myself now that i'm old
that's just quite an image i can i can
almost see it yeah i can tell you
another story similar
okay yeah please i'll tell you another
funny story somewhere we did no code of
conduct
uh for for dimension which was miramax
um
it was a 12 million film we shot we had
a green light on a script
charlie sheen starred in it and
we had written it they didn't want to
tell that story so they brought two
other writers on couple
of great guys ed masterson and bill
gaqwa really cool guys
we ended up becoming very good friends
for a long time actually one of them
bought a car from me
and we got to phoenix
and the director and charlie read the
script and they go what the what the
hell is this
and i said i don't know that's what they
sent you well we start shooting in 48
hours get your laptop
fade in so we rewrote the script
in arizona two days before we shot
from page one and just about page one
rewrite
that was another all same time of my
life it was within give or take a few
years so i was
still able to do that and how does that
work with the original credit
who cares we're just a bunch of dumb
people making movies you know i mean
they paid
they paid us we were producing the film
they paid the writers it was like they
had to deal with the writers anyway so
those it was like we wrote the film
charlie brett michaels and i wrote the
script and then
they agreed to make the movie we went to
phoenix to make the movie
and then somebody got in the mix and
said that's not the script we want to
make and hire two writers didn't tell us
anything about it and just sent us a
script
the guys never came out to arizona they
were just two guys in la that
were told to rewrite a script that they
weren't happy with
because it was originally written for la
and then they sent us to phoenix for a
tax credit so we get there and
it's just the domino effect you change
the script like what the hell is this
this isn't what we
you know charlie doesn't know why i'm
here i didn't agree to do this and it
was our company charlie brett and i had
a company so
yeah and they just said come on dynamo
and get some jolt cola or
you know get some coffee and fire it up
let's go and we did it we did a 48 hour
two days before we wrote or rewrote the
whole script and they i don't think they
ever knew it
so what was what was our 47 like
hour 47 i remember being
in the homestead village they hadn't set
us up in our homes yet
they gave us homes it was a 12 million
film in phoenix in the 90s that's a lot
of money
they had us in a homestead village and
we each had our own
unit and i remember being in brett's at
his cabinet
i probably i probably smoked three packs
of cigarettes
a day and just drank coffee
it was nuts and then there was a kenny
rogers roasters that that would deliver
right at the end it was like that that
episode of seinfeld
and i was like just living on kenny
rogers roasters for like
two weeks we were there and his last 48
hours went through like two buckets of
chicken it was
brutal it was brutal it smelled in there
and then i had a day and a half and i
remember joe lando from dr quinn was
co-starring in it he was our bad guy
and he was a dear friend he still is and
i remember going to my room
and collapsing and you know the sound of
a hotel phone ringing that loud chirp
it woke me up about 18 hours later and
have you ever woken up from asleep so
deep do you feel like you know
you got punched by mike tyson and you
just you're incoherent
i remember the phone ringing waking up
and literally i couldn't see my eyes
were open and i was i was like mike
tyson on his hands and knees when he got
knocked out and he was reaching remember
when he was looking for his mouthpiece
that was me looking for the phone i
answered it i had the upside down parts
of my ear
i was like hello and joe's like shane
it's joe it's like
and and he to this day he still makes
fun of me because i know the story and
he goes dude
are you okay okay oh yes and he goes i
think
i caught you is sleeping or something
i'm gonna call you back and i remember
it woke me up and i remember i had to
call him back and i couldn't find him
and i was worried something was wrong
but yeah that's that's what that was
like we started shooting i think the
next morning at 5am
with the script that the three of you
had had written yeah and then the
director decided at 5am he wanted to be
in the movie
and he wasn't written in the movie and
turned to me and said why don't you
direct the opening scene i'm going to be
in this
so that was my first directing job
really without getting a job so i shot
the opening scene of no code yeah the
director decided to be in it has dealing
with
kovid been the most difficult stretch
for you in your entire film career
dealing with covet has not been an issue
other than things got shut down i had a
film that was
ready to go that was green lit that we
were going to be shooting the june
after the march start of covid so that
was disappointing i've
never had a green light on a film and
watched it completely go away
that was kind of heartbreaking i felt
bad for the cast i felt bad for the crew
um i am never bored
i always find something to do and we've
been very very productive during covid i
think
between two writers and i we've created
over 30 pride three writers and i've
created with 30 projects
six screenplays uh i got involved with
a health and wellness documentary i've
been helping kind of oversee
for pure flix that's been fun
um but as i told you earlier i just got
to the point where i said it's time to
go back to work and you know people are
working there's a way to do this and i
have a lot of friends who have gotten
back on set and they're working
i've got partners up in canada right now
shooting a film for hallmark
got other friends that are here in town
shooting you know at siren they're doing
the will ferrell and julian moore film
and they're back to work
so we're chomping at the bit so i'm just
more restless now ready to go
what do you see as the new normal post
covid
whether whether a vaccine is found
whether people want to take the vaccine
it's still around people are still being
cautious
god if you're going to go two years on
this interview strand then
you're going to prove me wrong what do i
think the new normal is
i think i think the independent
filmmaker is going to
thrive i think those who wear many hats
and know how to make films on a dime are
going to thrive
because i wouldn't feel comfortable
taking
my normal investors investment now
i i am working with my investors at a
fraction
at one-fifth of their normal investment
strictly because i don't want
to be shut down during another pandemic
i don't want to
risk hurting a large crew getting people
sick i mean
like everybody else we're talking about
a care a story with maybe two actors
here and two here and maybe their story
lines will intersect maybe they won't
and knock this thing out in a short
amount of time with a crew of six or
eight
i think we'll generally get back i think
we'll get
i think we'll get to a point where
people are going to get very complacent
um i i compared to you know we did a
film
in the everglades years ago with emmett
and ferla
and the everglades and there's
alligators all around and your first day
on set
you're paranoid to move you're looking
and there's eight to twelve foot
alligators
everywhere you look and then about by
day three
you stop being paranoid and you get a
little more comfortable and then by day
four or five you're throwing a football
with somebody and then the guy's like
dude
you need to step forward about three
feet you got an eight-foot alligator
like literally right behind you
and i think that's how this is going to
become i think eventually
i i don't see a vaccine coming anytime
soon it's just not the way it works
and if they shipped it from overseas i
wouldn't take it so i think i
don't stand alone in that stance i think
we're happy to wear masks and ppe
and let's get the story told um
safety first but it's that way anyway
you know you're not going to put people
in dangerous situations so you figure
out a way to stay socially distant
responsible
i think if a crew can quarantine
together then they can work together
it's working and
you know it worked with football until
they all went home
it's worked with basketball i think
there's no reason we can't do that with
making our films i think the new normal
post covid while we have it is going to
be smaller crews
shorter dates of shooting uh and
just you know figuring it out you know
figuring it out
shane what protocols are you going to
take for your upcoming film
in this covid reopening well i mean you
first and foremost you have to
quarantine everybody out 14 days which
is important i think everybody needs to
know that they're clean
going in you have to test three times a
week anybody who's acting and anybody
who's in zone a
zone a is considered the director of the
dp hair and makeup department
anybody who's coming in regular contact
with the actors
and then anybody in zone b would be
tested once a week but when you have a
smaller crew
they assume everybody's in zone a so
everybody gets tested three times a week
so we'll test three times a week i am
going to take temperatures at least
twice a day i'd like taking temperatures
every morning and then every day after
lunch
unless we had something spicy for lunch
we'll do it before lunch
and we're just going to kind of stay
tight and be a traveling circus and just
keep it intimate and tight
not let any outsiders and not let
anybody from the inside go out it's like
hey if you're committing and you're in
you're in
if you're not that's cool we can't we
can't do this
obviously everybody's going to have to
wear ppe masks are going to be mandatory
actors will have to wear masks until we
say let's roll
action um actors are going to have to be
comfortable doing their own hair and
makeup even though we'll have somebody
that handles props hair and makeup and
wardrobe
i can't have them hovering so i want
actors to come
camera ready and they can be touched up
or not
doing a project that's elaborate we're
not doing mulan rouge
um wardrobe is going to be
owned by the cast we're going to use our
own wardrobe we're going to keep it
minimal changes
we're going to use locations that we
control we're not interested in using
these locations that are
used by the general public or rented or
chartered for the day they're going to
be okay we're going to
his house we're shooting at his house
today he's been quarantining there for
two weeks
we're going outside to this ranch we're
going outside to this
wash we're we're gonna do stuff outside
we have very minimal inside
actually the only interior scenes that
we have
is an office that has been closed
for months that a friend of mine owns
that he's given us and
a cabin out in the mountains that has
been vacated now for going on a year
so um we know it's clean and that's it
as everything else is exterior
or in a car and when you say
no one's going out so how do you how do
you ensure that the cast and crew
i mean i realize they're going to have
very little down time but somebody could
sneak down too
hey you know what it's on it's on them
if if they want to if they want to
jeopardize it i can't i'm you know
i i work with people i've known a long
time and i trust we're going to have a
crew of six to eight
we're gonna travel we're going to we're
going to be a traveling circus
so if somebody wants to sneak out of the
motorhome i'm going to probably know
they're sneaking out of the motorhome i
mean you know we got two motorhomes they
each sleep
they'll age sleep 10 but we're gonna
have a crew of six and four actors so
you know we'll know that's the only way
i do it is you gotta
you gotta keep some form of control you
know that's what's happened is football
why is football getting the covid
problem right now because
everything was controlled when these
guys were at training camp because they
were they were kept in a bubble just
like basketball successfully did
and then as we all said let's take an
office pool you want to go four weeks or
five before the nfl starts shutting down
games well
people go home then they start traveling
and then they come back from a game then
they go out with their friends and then
they go to a strip club or they go
wherever
and then they go play a game and then
these two teams play and these guys
mingle and then they take it all with
them
and that's what's happening that's why
you're seeing games getting canceled and
teams getting shut down we
you know it's happening now we're only
in week three
and we're not even in the cold season
and isn't that when covert is
that's what i think is going to be the
worst so yeah i mean we're going to
we're going to take all the precautions
necessary
um we're just yeah that's how we're
that's the only way we can do it it's
the only way we can do it
do you see yourself flying anytime soon
i love flying
but i mean it depends we have a plane in
the movie too
and somebody will be flying we got a
little piper cub but i mean in terms of
commercials taking a commercial flight
yes
with recycled i i would not right now
want to go on a plane
i would knowing knowing whether or not
i've been exposed to covet is the big
mystery in the house but
let's say i have i wouldn't want to get
on a plane now because i think for the
first time in our lifetime we're
thinking about
the air we breathe and the close contact
we make with people we don't know
and i because the way we've all had to
rethink and
relook at tight spaces oh the thought of
being on a plane with people right now
or ever i don't want to do it
how does a director build strong
relationships with her actors
director builds strong relationships
with actors you know it's all about
trust
it's an actor's gonna decide in the
first
30 seconds of meeting a director if this
is somebody they can work with
they've they've sized you up it's almost
like having a blind date
they size you up when you walk through
the door what can i get away with
what are they going to command for me
are they going to stretch me and make me
into something better or can i put this
in cruise control and just kind of ride
it out
and what i found is i i like to listen
to an actor
um i like to let an actor know that i i
run a set that's very relaxed
i i'm not a yeller i i trust i said if
you're here it's because i trust you
now we just got to get to the point
where you trust me
so i let actors know that
you know what's important to me is i get
the movie that we need to make
give me what i need and i'll give you
what you want every time if you
show up prepared and you're able to give
me and the time allotted to do the scene
what i need
i will give you what you want and i know
nine times out of ten what you want is
going to be better than what i need
and i find when i tell and that's true
that's not lip service i don't say that
to every actor but you know when i'm
dealing with my leads and people that i
trust that have earned that
i find that barrier comes down and they
start to get excited and realize that
this is a safe place
you know i i learned something very
interesting from martin sheen
when we were doing a film together 100
years ago he was telling the story when
he had a heart attack on apocalypse now
and he was being wheeled into surgery
and his dear wife jan
looked over him and said it's only an f
in movie
martin and he told that story but
apocalypse now is one of the most
known films in our history it's huge
and i never forgot that story
and i never forgot that
it's only a movie you know
relationships are forever there's 33 000
movies a year that are probably made
through sag
why is this one going to be any more
special than the next or less important
than the next it's only a movie
we're not curing cancer we're not curing
kovid
what's most important is people feel
better after the experience than they
did coming into it for me
and i want my actors to feel respected i
want them to feel like they can grow
i want them to feel like they can
challenge me because i hope i become a
better filmmaker because of our
experience you know and
i think if you go in allowing an
actor to stretch their legs keep them
reined in when you have to
but trust when you make a decision on an
actor that is who you have entrusted
that role
and that story to be told by through
their eyes and their vision
i think it's important to let an actor
feel like they
they can have the freedom to play and to
explore and experiment
and then as a as a director and an actor
i think you can find that middle ground
where you're getting the story
and the performance that you need as a
filmmaker
but as an actor and an artist they're
being able to
to fly in a way that they don't feel
stifled or congested
or condemned and i think if you can find
that balance
when you look at some of the great
relationships that some directors and
actors have i mean you can look at
spielberg and tom hanks
or zemeckis and tom hanks when they work
together on castaway and some of the
other films and
um you you try to get one 100th of that
greatness or that relationship and and i
find that
i i've never walked away working from it
never walked away working with an actor
regretting the experience didn't matter
who it was or what the project was i've
never walked away from an actor
regretting it and i hope they feel the
same for me
do you think um most sets are as
stressful as apocalypse now was or or
what percentage i should say
i think i ever reached that point i
think a lot of sets are unnecessarily
stressful
it's something i talk about in my book i
think especially young filmmakers put
so much stress and pressure
they are making a movie because
goddammit it's getting in the sundance
are our bust
and that is like the least thing you
should be worried about make a good
movie
learn and enjoy this experience you may
never do it again it's like
it's like they tell you and rudy you
know you may be putting on the football
uniform for the last time enjoy it live
in the moment and i tell filmmakers that
this could be your one and only chance
to tell a story as a director before it
fails and you have to go sell stocks or
become an insurance salesman or whatever
it is that you could do
nothing wrong with that but being a
filmmaker is a dream okay there's very
few people who can make a living at it
so i always tell people look this is
this could be the only time you're ever
going to do it you might as well enjoy
it
and i think if you enjoy it and the
people around you
feel that you're enjoying it it's going
to be a much more pleasurable experience
when people are happy they deliver
better things
i find that people put unnecessary
stress on
themselves because they they just
don't see it with the end in mind
they're so worried about what they're
getting
and i think that's the importance of
being
knowledgeable in editorial every
filmmaker before they want to
you know before they become a director
before they become a writer i think they
need to spend
three to five years in the edit bay
fixing other people's mistakes
because one reason i'm able to
maintain a good demeanor i know when i
make a film it's because
i know when i nail something how i'm
going to use it i know exactly how many
frames of it i'm going to use i know
exactly where in the story i'm going to
use it
and it just it's not arrogance it's just
confidence it's knowing the craft of
telling a story doesn't mean my movies
are great but
i look at something and i don't
overshoot i don't get a lot of takes i
don't need it
i trust my cameraman i trust my actors
and i trust myself
to tell the story and i think if people
can just kind of
and it goes back to hiring the right
people people can just kind of take a
breath
and enjoy the moment and just realize
that we are so blessed to be able to do
this
i think they'd be pretty surprised with
the
the outcome that they get when they look
at the dailies i think they'd be
pleasantly surprised
and with apocalypse now weren't there
things just completely out of
copela's control that i mean what they
were going on with the
government at the time you know with
with the different locations there is
things happen there is always problems
on a film and as i as i try to stress
and we've talked about earlier i over
pre-produce a film
so that way when something when a little
bit you know wheel comes off the wagon
or a lug nut gets loose
it's not a catastrophe i'll give you an
example we were doing our last film
i wrote a part or you know cj wrote a
part
with with my request for a specific
actor i was a big fan of i
fell in love with an actor on a show i
knew i could get to them
and i wrote a part for them and we made
a deal and this actor was going to be
part of the film
and long story short
the day we showed up to shoot i got a
call from her agent she said her father
just died she's got to jump on a plane
and go to detroit we're so sorry
just reschedule it she'll she'll be back
in five six days
rescheduled i said i wish i could it's
the only time i'm here
we work at a very quick pace we got to
figure this out i said i'm going to go
to you first you have another actor you
want to give me that you feel can do the
role
and he was funny he was like i can't
believe you're not freaking out i said
no i'm concerned about the actor and her
well-being for her dad
i will reach out to her but i said i
want you to think about somebody you
have on your roster you've got
you've got 20 minutes before i start
making calls to other agents and he
called me he said i've got somebody
and i don't want to name names but it
ended up being a pretty damn good cat
and it's it's about not losing it it's
about just taking a breath and realizing
it's only a movie it'll all figure
itself out
that's what we have to do you know um
the only way to make it work you know
our biggest day of shooting on break
even i had
nine cameras i had an entire cast and
half my crew get food poisoning at the
hotel from bad ice
where our call time that day was 8 a.m
we're supposed to start rolling cameras
at 10.
i think people started showing up around
12 30 or 1 the ones that did show up and
didn't go to the hospital and i didn't
start shooting my biggest day of the
film
until 1 30 2 o'clock and
i i had a choice i could yell and scream
i could
throw a fit i could kick a seagull
was it the ocean and i realized getting
upset wasn't going to make
my casting group better it was only
going to
let my existing cast and crew realize i
was out of control
and i decided to just deal with what we
got let's make it work
and you know it worked of course when i
watched the scene back i wish i would
have had more time
of course when i watched a scene back i
wish i would have gotten more angles
but i'm pleased with what we got and
because of my knowledge
in post i knew exactly how we had to do
this now with a
fraction of the time and it just comes
from
confidence in telling a story being
understanding the editorial process so
those are things that are out of your
control you know shot another scene and
there was a construction you know we
went and scouted it got a permit
had a whole scene and it turned out they
started building a house or demolishing
a house right across from it
you know what do you do that's out of
your control and it's a very dialogue
heavy scene that you know you're not
going to loot
so you you find the nicest person and
the most reasonable person on your crew
to go over and talk to the foreman
and work out say hey we're here for two
hours can we do this can we
we go you go we go you go and they
worked with us
you know it's what it's about what did
gary busey teach you about being a
director
gary busey taught me so much about being
a director the first
narrative i ever directed start gary
busey
so talk about you know baptism under
fire
um gary is unbelievably talented
gary is he bro you know he brought 40
years to the table
i mean there's a guy had done you know
75 movies when i worked with him at this
point here i was directing my first i of
course produced and written a lot of
stuff and never directed before
so i learned how to
take a punch and i don't mean physically
i mean i learned how to take a punch and
learn how to
to improvise i learned how to be strong
because when you're working with an
actor like your abuse you're the late
dennis hopper
those guys are constantly testing you
they they get
more pleasure out of trying to break you
to find out how tough you
are and they're going to decide what
they're going to give you with your
toughness
and i found you know when i produced a
film with marlon brando and i know his
tricks and what he used to do to
directors and i'd watch him do it and
he would give two takes that were almost
identical and see which one the director
liked better and if he knew the director
like the one he didn't really care about
then he he phoned it in he didn't care
and he he messed with directors and gary
messes with directors and dennis messed
with directors
and i i encourage new filmmakers to go
work with guys like that
because if you can cut your teeth on
that
it's it's gonna you're gonna learn
you're gonna have seven years of film
school in one day with a guy like that
and what was really cool about gary is
the way he helped me develop the
character and work through the character
and what he demanded and commanded of me
as a filmmaker before we started he was
very involved in
working this out and making it happen
and then when he showed up on set
it was so neat i remember we did take
one and i remember i said
and cut and eternity goes notes
give me notes and i was like i got 25
people looking at me waiting for me to
go tell gary busey academy award winner
or academy award nominee golden globe
guy
you know tell him and i was scared to
death and i walked up to him
and i realized what it was it was a show
and i just went up to i put my hands on
his elbows to see gary
that was freaking brilliant i want to
get it again
will that make you happy and you look at
me and goes dude come on they're all
looking at us give me a goddamn note
alec i said a little bit more pause when
you go to sit down
before you give him that line that you
know and he goes
there we go and that was the only noted
game all day just because he wanted a
note
and i was so out of my league at the
time and it's so out of out of the you
know
knowing how to deal with the moment and
he covered me but
he he he didn't need the note
he he showed up more prepared than
anybody and
just knocked it out of the park and did
exactly what i had hoped he would and we
had rehearsed it but
he tried to toughen me up and show me
that i need to be more vocal as a
filmmaker in front of people don't just
say action
cut that was great let's get it again
you know that was
it it's about interacting and i learned
so much from that experience and you
know i've worked with some great actors
you know like jane seymour and
you know dennis hopper and you know good
lord the list goes on and on and
um every one of those gives so much to
each
project that we've done together and i
learn so much but gary yeah gary
gary was baptism by fire he kicked my
ass right into gear
that was i knew once i once i rapped on
busy
life got really easy it's amazing
why would an actor on that level of that
caliber
want to test someone they
it's about i think control it's about
how much
i am willing to give and i'm not it's
like i look at it as a relationship
if you're in a relationship with
somebody and you're
interested in taking that next level of
intimacy
you're going to put some feelers out to
see if this is somebody that you can
trust
and go that deep with emotionally and i
think actors like to try to break you
down some of them are just
flat out and like to control a
set and those are who they are and
gary was not that way at all what he
wanted to do is he wanted to see he
wanted to push my limits to see how much
he was willing to give back
and the reason he wanted to do the film
it's a funny story i
sent the script to his son jake to play
a part
gary intercepted it called me and said
jake's not available he's in miami doing
a pilot for nbc
i read the script who's playing earl
cooper and i was like uh uh and there
was an actor kind of attached and he
goes well i want to play it i've done 75
films and i've never read a character
like this or been able to play this part
and i'd really like to play them
i mean i i sorry to kind of bogart the
script but i i want to do it
he wasn't looking for a job he was busy
and i wasn't paying anything so it
wasn't like he was getting any money
um so i went and met with him at his
house and we talked and just
the first time i sat with an actor of
that caliber and listened to him break
down a script that i wrote
and what he did is he taught me the
importance of what happens off the page
you know he said look you you know shane
you've given me
you've given me page one to page 88.
i'm more interested about what's before
page one
and that's his story you know and gary
went into
this guy's childhood and what made him
who he is today and it
it really opened my mind as a
storyteller and as a writer and as a
director because now i understood how
actors thought
so it was an amazing experience that i
would work with gary 100 times over and
you know twice on sunday it was a great
experience
you